Mr clerk would you call the roll
uh representative Gordon
I'm here
representative Sylvia is not here
representative Sylvia not here The Quirk
is here
representative green here representative
norter
representative merner
representative Kelly
representative trottier
a representative
holy smokes well just reading
representative Andrews representative
Smith representative Birch
representative Oregon
representative De Lorenzo
representative Chase
representative Kenny
representative Langley
representative Chase are you here
[Laughter]
uh representative Macbeth
representative page and representative
Simpson yeah
okay we have the beginning attendance
and we do not have the Quorum we do not
need
right we are not required to have a
quorum
I just would note for those people who
have appeared here today there are a
number of people who are absent we have
several people who are ill and we do
have other people who have other
commitments including other legislative
commitments today and I'm sure that they
will be in and out as the day progresses
our first item of business this morning
is
cacr21 relating to registers of probate
the primary sponsor of that bill is
representative silver and will call upon
him this morning to give his testimony
and introduce the bill
thank you I'm Norman Silber I'm a
representative from Belknap District 2
which is the towns of Guilford and
Meredith and I live in Guilford
oh
and I'm a member of the New Hampshire
bar as well uh
I was fascinated by the local or by the
elections when I moved here 10 so years
ago that we had this office of register
of probate and I tried to figure out in
looking through the the Constitution and
the statute books and everything else
what do they do and I realized that they
have one major Duty since the court
reorganization in 2011 when the duties
were basically transferred to the clerks
of the Probate Court the main duty is to
take the nice fancy certificate that you
get from the Secretary of State
attesting to the fact you were elected
and finding a framer to put that in a
frame for you
um I I saw that I think
another representative at one time said
that they get a letter from the judicial
branch stating the court will not
provide a telephone office desk or key
to the courthouse
so there's basically it's an anachronism
and it's like as I've said to me it's
like a buggy whip Factory or something
these days and we don't have buggy whips
anymore and so the register of probate
is really an anachronism this is a
housekeeping bill I view this as a
housekeeping Bill uh there will be
another speaker a representative from I
think from the judicial branch who found
a section of the rsas that OLS missed
where it needs to be added by a brief
Amendment to the repealer so it was
basically eliminating a position that
has no duties and uh you know should
just clean up the Constitution
and I'll be happy to answer any
questions
questions for representative Silber
seeing none are you going oh
representative wolper so representative
silver that my understanding the primary
function of the registrar probate is to
ensure the uh
uh what they call that permanence of our
records
and I'm wondering how that's going to
happen if there is no register of
probate
I'm not I'm not aware that they actually
have any duties at all I believe that
the court clerk is responsible for the
maintenance of all the records of the
Court including the probate records
any other questions
excuse me by the way the reason I'm not
wearing a mask is because I had covet
last year and got over it so I have a
high immunity level so
okay
okay seeing no other questions thank you
representative thank you very much for
your attention
this person to testify would be judge
king
excuse me
sure
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for
coming here this morning and
taking the time to take up this what I
think is very very important bill cacr21
my name is David King
I am the administrative judge of the New
Hampshire circuit court before we had a
circuit court I was the administrative
judge of the probate court and before
that for 17 years I was a just a plain
old probate judge so for 32 years I've
been a judge in some fashion in the
system dealing with the probate court
now probate Division and while I don't
profess to be an expert on very many
things I think
I'm pretty familiar with the register of
probate office in the history and I
agree with representative Silber that
while this is a constitutional amendment
it really is almost a housekeeping bill
at this point and hopefully I'll be able
to convince you of that uh this the
amendment that representative Silber
referenced would be and we will provide
an amendment for the committee we just
came up this morning article 81
says that registers of probate cannot
act as counsel in any matter and that
should be changed as well if this
Constitutional Amendment moves forward
but the register of probate office was
created in 1694 77 it was put into the
Constitution
institution
there's a handout that Richard had as a
handing out now that's been recycled
over the last 15 years many times it's
probably been submitted at least 15
times as exhibits in various forms but
it has a pretty interesting history of
the register of probate office in it
which I'm not going to go into
other than to say that a lot has changed
in the court system over the last 145
years
the significant changes in the court
system began in 1983 in the legislature
when we became a unified court system
and I had the good fortune and privilege
to serve on this Committee in that that
legislative session 38 years ago when I
was 15 years old
and it was House Bill 200 representative
scitec who later became speaker of the
house was chair of the committee and we
essentially in House Bill 200 took a
county and municipal-based court system
and made it a state system
the registers of probate who were County
Employees elected officials remained in
the system as now state employees
and because it would involve a
constitutional amendment House Bill 200
didn't deal with that I think the
thought at the time was we'll come back
and deal with that later and today I'm
suggesting it later
elected registers as I said stayed as
part of the court system
it wasn't a great system 10 different
ways of doing things
during the time that they were full-time
salaried employees in our the payroll
when in 2011 when they were essentially
eliminated was about a million dollars a
year for the Ten of them with benefits
but they were able to set their own
hours some of them showed up when they
wanted to uh you'll see in the materials
that there was a register from one
County who was elected in her 80s from a
nursing home
um we had a register during my time as
administrative judge who did not believe
that people should be defaulted or that
we should send out citations so for a
two-year period that Court sent out no
defaults or citations which are required
by Statute
we had a newly elected register that
thought it would be good to strip down
the file so they weren't as thick so it
would shred parts of the files which
included unfortunately until we found
out about it inventories from
guardianships which have the book and
page in it if you're trying to do a
title search there's going to be a hole
with some of those records
and then one register who was elected in
a contested election and I met with her
as the administrative judge and was
curious why this person ran for office
and the response was well my nephew was
on probation once and I thought it would
be interesting to see what the Probate
Court does having no idea at all what
the Probate Court did
and as I said they were pretty highly
compensated at that time so in 2011 we
created what is now called the circuit
court with House Bill 609 it came
through this committee it was fully
vetted we took 52 clerks and registers
in courts around the state and we
collapsed that management structure down
to 18. we had hoped to do it over 10
years which would
would be expiring just about now but the
legislature loved the idea and it
required us to do it by the beginning of
the fiscal year so in three months we
collapsed the management structure from
52 clerks and registers down to 18.
and as I said we were and completely
transparent about the future of the
probate registers my testimony from the
Senate is included in the materials and
what I said is if they don't show up for
work we'll be okay
interesting to note that the registers
were all fairly politically active at
the time none of them showed up in the
house or Senate to testify on House Bill
609 and trust me they were never shy
about speaking up when they wanted to be
heard
and in that bill we paired their duties
down
basically to nothing with the
expectation that after a few election
Cycles we would come back and ask for a
constitutional amendment and we've now
been through five election Cycles after
House Bill 609 we've had primaries where
no one signed up to run for register of
probate this year in Grafton County for
example in the general election the
register of probate one with 170 votes
um and if you compare that to the
register of deeds which is also a county
office that individual got 47
467 votes versus 170.
you'll be interested to know
representative Gordon and in Bristol you
got 1207 votes and the successful
register probably got two votes so I
think it shows you how people view the
significance of the register of probate
office and in the same county two or
three terms ago a young man who was a
fraternity brother at Dartmouth by the
name of Mickel wapinski got elected
and they thought it would be a gag if
one of the fraternity Brothers could be
the register of probate and sure enough
was elected the good news is he beat out
keggy the kegger who got the second most
number of votes in Grafton County that
year and I met with Mr Lipinski after he
was elected obviously very intelligent
young man he's at Dartmouth and he kind
of apologized and said we had a party we
thought it would be a gag if one of us
got elected and I wanted to make sure he
was not in any trouble and I said as
long as you don't come back you won't be
in any trouble at all so he he was
leaving for New York and I never saw him
again
we have only one probate register left
who was a register under the old system
it's Terry Peterson up in the first
circuit if I couldn't ask Terry to come
today she's got several people out with
illnesses but if she were here she would
sister of probate we get about eleven
thousand thousand probate cases a year
in the Circuit Court which is about
eight percent of our volume
we have gone to electronic filing for
almost all of our probate cases I've put
some statistics in your materials uh
which you're free to look at but it's
suffice it to say that ninety percent of
all probate cases are centralized here
in Concord the local courts don't even
know about Estates or name changes
because they're all done centrally
unless there's a need for a hearing
that's about three percent of the estate
cases and even in those situations where
hearing is needed we try to do the
hearings virtually centrally unless we
absolutely need an Evidence you're
hearing so the 10 probate divisions
scattered around the state don't do any
probate work anymore essentially
um
we have an information center that
answers every single phone call that
comes into the Circuit Court they've
taken 4.4 million calls since we began
I've put the probate call volumes in
your materials you'll see in an average
non-pandemic here we get about 50 000
Probate Court calls ER probate division
calls a year
uh none of those have been fielded by a
register of probate over the last 10 and
a half years and when we went to
electronic filing we kept our pledge to
the legislature to reduce our staff and
we actually reduced 10.7 probate
division employees around the state uh
between the shrinking management the
reduction in ftes for electronic filing
and other innovations that we've created
in the Circuit Court we've saved the
taxpayers of New Hampshire over 60
million dollars over the last 10 years
so I'll end by saying that the circuit
Court's been on in operation for 10 and
a half years with absolutely no
contribution from the registers of
probate I think our track record proves
that they're obsolete it's not 1694
anymore it's 2022 and it's time to
finish the job that representative
scitec started back in 1983.
I have yet to hear any good argument in
favor of keeping them except that's the
way it's always been so I would ask you
to please support this bill and I'm
happy to answer any questions that you
might have
questions for judge king
yes representative Chase thank you very
much much Mr chair and thank you judge
king for taking my question
I'm not a lawyer I have used probate I
was guardian of my daughter for seven
years until she passed away and I would
do that call in and then they'd ask me
what county I was from and then they
would send me over to the county probate
which actually was
Stratford
yes so the one in Kingston
and the probate person there was the one
that did all the paperwork and all and
she would answer my questions Karen I
think her name is so is this saying that
she wouldn't be available anymore they
would get dissolved that and everything
would be done in Concord no Karen B
Shard is still at the probate court in
Brentwood um Brentwood thank you yes but
we also have a probate specialist
embedded in the information center now
who try we try to keep as many calls at
the information center because we're so
short staffed in the courts but Karen
would still be available if you needed
some specialized question about the
guardianship case and I should say the
difference between the Estates and the
name changes which are essentially 100
centralized all of the guardianship
cases ultimately go out to the 10
probate divisions for a hearing because
they all require a hearing so that's
that's a little bit of a difference
between those cases
follow up yes thank you very much so if
this was to be abolished does that mean
people are going to lose their jobs as
well how does that work well there are
10 elected probate registers right now
they are paid a hundred dollars a year
and if this is passed I assume they
would collect their salary for the
balance of this term but they would they
would not be running for re-election the
next time so our payroll went from
essentially a million dollars a year
down to a thousand dollars a year for
the registers of probate awesome all
right thank you for clarifying
representative D Lorenzo I'm pretty much
all set Mr chairman um my question was
about the salary I do want to say that I
had the opportunity to visit
um the Circuit Court where the probate
department is um
located and it was very very very
impressive with the new kiosk and the
systems and the workers were very very
busy and very very happy so I
really
admire the work that's been done by
Justice King thank you for that
representative Lorenzo I appreciate that
other questions
yes representative Horrigan
you turn on your microphone
there now you can hear me so my uh
my question is what there's still
numerous uh references well not numerous
but a significant number of references
to uh
in the statute law to the register of
probate so what happens to those during
if we pass this Constitutional Amendment
between
when the Constitutional Amendment takes
effect and uh when we would be able to
update the laws if we updated the laws
so what
yep excellent question representative so
when we created the Circuit Court it was
it's now chapter 490f and you'll see a
catch-all provision in 490f that says
any prior reference to the district
court the probate court of the family
division is now a reference to the
Circuit Court and any reference to
registers of probate is now a reference
to Clerks of the circuit court so we've
we we cleaned that up we could probably
go back if you know the probate statutes
at all it would be a real maze to try to
figure out everywhere that word is but
it could be done but I don't think it
would be necessary at this point
yeah let's go follow it please and if
I'm not don't they have some minor
duties like preserving their uh
authorized to preserve the uh historical
probate records in fact there's even
some funding for them to work with the
state archives So like um so are they
totally so is my view correct or in your
opinion they're totally without any
function whatsoever at the moment no
they clearly have a function in the
statute which is to maintain the ancient
record the practical
situation is that they have for 10 years
not done it the clerks have done that
our clerks are trying uh to clean out
the courthouses because we're running
out of space and so we've worked with
Brian Burford at The Archives to get as
many probate records as we can there's
tension between that and the title
abstractors who would like to keep the
records locally but as a practical
matter the registers of probate in the
10 Counties have not been involved in
that process okay all right thanks
any other questions for judge Kane
yes representative Chase hi this is the
question it's a comment as uh
representative Lorenzo said this the new
system that you have is great I enjoy I
don't enjoy it are you having to go on
there but um it's so much easier from
even when I started my guardianship with
my daughter and had to go in and being
not understanding all the forms and now
everything is so simple to find easy to
do and also the follow-up if you do have
questions so thank you again I just
wanted to comment and thank you for
thank you for rearranging that I know
you came in last session and told us
about it and it's been great thank you
other questions
or comments
seeing none thank you Mr chairman thank
you for your testimony today
and
representative Lynn
all right
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee I also appear here in support
of this proposed Constitutional
Amendment
um and I agree with with really
everything that has been said by the the
two prior Witnesses the one point that I
would make and I think it has some
significance I know this has been
referred to as kind of a housekeeping
matter and in many respects it it really
is but you know I think that there I I
think that there really is a need to do
this I mean that you know as some of you
may know uh uh just very recently
retired Secretary of State Bill Gardner
has some question about doing what was
done by Statute as opposed to by
Constitutional Amendment
um I was in very much in favor of the
the statutory change because it needed
to be done
um you know you know under the old
system
I mean I guess the analogy I would draw
is suppose that in this legislature our
legislative Services people were elected
on their own and had kind of their own
constituency and when we said you know
listen we want you to give priority to
putting this information together to us
they could say well you know we don't
think our constituency would would
support that we want to we want to
follow this this role I think we would
we would go nuts we would say wait a
minute how can we how can we run this
branch of government where there's
another you know somebody that's
supposed to provide essential services
to us sort of has their own agenda and
that was kind of what existed under the
old system with elected registers There
Was You know I can remember I was in in
the court system at the time I mean
there was one register of probate who
essentially wintered in Florida every
year collected a full salary and
wintered in Florida
um and you know
was very popular among the electorate
and so it was you know there not a lot
that could be done about that so it was
very very important I think that this be
done uh I was as I said I was a strong
supporter of making the statue change
but I mean I think I also think it's
fair to say that
there is at least Bill Gardner I think
had has at least a an argument that the
proper way for this to be done should be
by Constitutional Amendment it's long
overdue the registers don't serve any
any useful purpose anymore the clerks
perform the work very very well uh much
more efficiently
um and so I think this would you know it
you can characterize it as kind of a
housekeeping but it's a little bit more
than that it really I think I think
substantly if substantively is something
that needs to be done and I hope uh that
you'll uh that you'll do that and I'm
happy to answer any questions
any questions for uh representative Lynn
well representative Horrigan
um just representative Lynn I assume you
presumably had
as many of us had had lengthy
discussions with Bill Gardner about this
and the million other topics he was an
expert on but um was he
recall if he like was supportive of the
Constitutional Amendment when you spoke
to him or not because I actually
considered introducing something like
this a number of years ago and he was he
he actually I thought talked me out of
it of course sometimes it's hard to tell
what Bill actually said it was very but
yeah so so see so have you did you
discuss it with him did he weigh in one
way or the other on uh on whether or not
there's constitutional member is a good
idea nothing not that we have to do what
he tells them to especially since he's
not here anymore
no no thank you very much for the
question representative the answer is no
you know I actually never directly
discussed this with with uh uh secretary
Gardner but I did know you know he had
from statements that he had made that he
was concerned about sort of doing this
by uh by Statute but that's the extent
of my knowledge of it okay you have
agreed thanks
any other questions for representative
Lynn
thank you
is there anyone else here who would like
to testify on cacr21
seeing no one we will close the hearing
on CRC ACR 21.
and we will be in a very short recess
until 9 30 when we will begin our next
hearing
many years ago when I first met Josh
okay
and we imagine
very smart
okay
foreign
we'll call the house Judiciary Committee
back to order
our next item of business today is a
hearing on House Bill 1140.
this is relative to probate procedures
for small Estates
primary sponsor of that bill is
representative Terry and I understand
that is here he is here to introduce
that bill welcome representative
Mr chairman honorable colleagues and
members of the committee I'm
representative Paul Terry from Alton and
I'm here this morning to speak to HB
1140 the bill I have introduced that if
enacted will provide New Hampshire
citizens with a simplified
or summary probate procedure for small
Estates
back in the fall of last year
I inquired of OLS as to the existence of
such a law in New Hampshire and was told
we do not have this type of law
prompted by my experience serving as the
executor for both my late fathers and
mother's Estates in two different states
and having two quite different
experiences in each state I was moved to
seek the better of the two
in our state
staff for the National Conference of
State legislatures have informed me that
almost all states have either or both of
two simplified estate procedures
so if this bill becomes law we would be
joining these states who have seen the
wisdom
in providing citizens with simple and
fairly low Estates a way to move quickly
through the probate process and get on
with their lives
I'd like to acknowledge with thanks The
Entity fined law for the following
helpful and fairly concise information
about small Estates and the ways most of
our states have provided for their
Administration
quote
generally probate for large Estates can
take years or even decades
however for smaller Estates there's a
simplified version of the process often
called simplified probate or summary
probate
almost all states with the exception of
a few
allow this simplified probate procedure
that saves money
and time
Most states allow summary probate as
long as the estate doesn't exceed a
certain limit
the amount of estate often refers to the
dollar value of the property that's in
the estate which varies by state
as opposed to the regular probate
process summary probate typically won't
require a court hearing
instead beneficiaries can use Simple
methods to distribute the assets
the summary probate process starts when
the executor
or the surviving family member files a
petition for summary probate
the petition should indicate the amount
of the estate and a statement on how it
meets the limit to qualify for summary
probate under state law
there is a will related to the estate
the petition should also show that the
will is valid
next the executor will need to submit
supporting documents to go along with
the petition for summary probate
the court will require the executor to
attach a copy of the will in a list of
errors and property assets
after the petition for summary probate
is submitted the summary probate process
goes into a waiting period
which gives creditors
an opportunity to file claim against the
petitioner
this period for summary probate usually
lasts a month or two
which is much shorter than the regular
probate
then the estate must pay an out all
outstanding taxes in debts and after
that the assets will be distributed to
the appropriate heirs once final asset
distributions distributions are made the
estate is closed
close quote
under the uniform probate code UPC there
are two different methods for simplified
probate affidavit and summary
Administration
because my positive experience as an
executor occurred in Rhode Island I have
utilized that State's law as a model and
its prescribed method of summary
Administration
I'm intrigued by the affidavit model but
consideration may wait for another year
understanding that some states offer it
only or as a choice in addition to
summary Administration
it's my thought that we see how summary
Administration excuse me yeah summary
Administration works here
as it does in 34 other states
as you as you might expect different
states have different threshold limits
Connecticut's is 40 000. Massachusetts
is 25 000. Rhode Islands is 15 000 and
Vermont is forty five thousand most
other states in other regions of the
country exceed these limits
including California whose limit is
166 thousand two hundred and fifty
dollars
New York fifty thousand and I actually
have a chart here if anyone is
interested at any point which shows the
limits in all of the 34 states
I selected twenty five thousand for HB
1140 as an initial conservative amount
to determine how our state would respond
of course if this committee were to
select a higher threshold I would not be
at all opposed
I believe this bill is a winner
for all parties concerned
simplified probate for small Estates has
worked very well throughout the United
States and I have every reason to
believe it or will work just as well
here in New Hampshire and to the best of
my knowledge no state that has adopted
one of the two procedures summary
Administration or affidavit has repealed
their laws
given the number of states that have
simplified probate for small Estates
clearly this is not a Republican or
Democrat partisan matter
I believe too that this bill is a
bipartisan measure that ought to make
everyone happy
and that can only rarely be said of the
house and among all of our fellow
citizens
while I'm not an attorney I'd be pleased
to respond to any questions you may have
and if I am unable to provide an answer
now perhaps one of the others here who
may be testifying
may be able to do so if not I'll do my
best to find the answer and get back to
you and if anyone is interested in a
copy of my written testimony and
supporting documents I'd be happy to
provide them to you upon request thank
you
this is a request can you send that to
us electronically yes
the the testimony and the supporting
documents
okay be happy to do that now may I do
that through the clerk and have the
clerk distribute to the members or do
you want me to mail to the email to all
the members individually all the
committee there's there's one email link
for the entire community that would be
perfect I'd be happy to do that thank
you you're very welcome
questions for representative Terry
representative Lorenzo
thank you Mr chair and thank you um
representative Terry for your testimony
um you know I was going back into the
cupboards of my mind back when I was in
college and um that was in Massachusetts
and
I learned about Mass probate which has
which has a process called a voluntary
Administration which would be similar to
this process now in Massachusetts the
limit is twenty five thousand dollars
the limit of the estate is 25 000.
does your bill include the value of an
automobile
I do not believe that the the bill
itself specifies automobile
uh so the value of the automobile would
therefore fall within the calculation
for the 25
000 limit or whatever limit
the legislature would choose to SEC
thank you
by the way I had the same question at
the time that I was executing uh my
mother's estate in Rhode Island thank
you
well thinking about the value of cars
today do you think it might make sense
to amend this bill to include or exclude
the value of a vehicle
I don't see why not
thank you
other questions for representative Terry
see none thank you for your testimony
thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of the committee and I'll I'll
get this testimony and supporting
documents off to you within a couple of
days thank you thank you
representative Silber
a co-sponsor
thank you very much Mr chairman once
again I'm representative Norman Silber
from Belknap 2 towns of Guilford and
Meredith I live in Guilford I'm a member
of the New Hampshire bar since 2008 and
a member of the Florida bar since
1970.
hard to believe
in over 50 years of practice in Florida
I've done you know probably well in
excess of 100 or more probate matters I
started out my career professional
career in a in a Trust Company on Wall
Street doing an overdosing I say
overdosing on trust in Estates
the Florida summary procedure law not
terribly different than this has a
seventy five thousand dollar threshold
um I and it's all done all the unless
there's a will contest or something like
that if there's no contest involved
everything probate is handled
electronically which works out
efficiently I have handled dozens of
Florida summary administrations for New
Hampshire residents for through their
their law firms up here uh because it's
so easy to do and it's very simplified
analytically I think it's important to
think about
what contact the average citizen has
with the legal system
you buy or sell a house
you may end up getting divorced
you should have a will and perhaps a
trust drawn
um
hopefully you don't get involved in
civil litigation so I think the average
citizen in our state has little contact
with the legal system
but when they get involved in in Probate
matters
you know it can sometimes get to be very
frustrating for the average citizen and
they're wondering about why you know why
it's taking so long why they need to
hire a lawyer why it's so expensive and
all these different things
one aspect of Motor Vehicles because
that's always an issue there's a motor
vehicle in the name of the deceased
person you look up on Kelly Blue Book or
something like that and you find out the
value and all of a sudden you've eaten
up part of your threshold if not
completely as the representative pointed
out
um
an easy way to do that of course is to
title your car in the name of yourself
and your spouse so that when one of them
passes away it goes to the other outside
of probate but that's a different matter
so but I'm I'm in support of this
basically of simplifying the system for
our average citizens that are having
small Estates uh
you somebody passes away and you cancel
a magazine subscription and you get a
refund check for 1.75 or you have a
small you have a bank account you find a
bank account of a thousand dollars or
something like that uh
right now we've got a backlog in our
court system because of covet
everything is backlogged everybody is
short-handed this is something that
would be very good for our citizens
because it would simplify everything
reduce expenses reduce the burden on the
courts and more importantly reduce the
burden to our citizens so I'll be happy
to answer any questions
any questions for representation yes
representative Chase
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
I had a situation my youngest brother
passed away and did not have a will or a
state or an executor of what he didn't
have anyway so I tried to close out his
bank accounts and I didn't know what was
in them I wasn't allowed to know I had I
went and showed the death certificate
they told me I needed to become executor
I knew there wasn't much there he was
homeless
so I did do all this but it was going to
cost me much more when I got the
information back from the court as
though um I just figured I didn't do it
because I think it was over a hundred
dollars that I had to pay to become
executive just to know what the heck was
in this account I chose not to and let
it run out and let them deal with the
bank fees
um but it is this kind of what we're
talking about that small little thing
and do does the deceased have to leave
an Executor noted somewhere I don't I
don't believe so and you know the the
line that we sort of use is if you don't
leave a will
the state has made a will for you
we have intestacy laws that basically
says that if you die without a will in
other words you are intestate
here's who gets who's who gets to Who's
Who here's who gets the assets and here
is who gets to be appointed executor
administrator or whatever so if you
don't make a will the state's made one
for you in the rsas already so yes but
but if you see the fee in representative
Terry's bill is I think 30 bucks I mean
it's really very very nominal and so it
it would really simplify things
the questions for representative Silber
representative Lorenzo
thank you Mr chair and thank you um
representative Silber for your testimony
I have a question about some of the
language on the bill
um
right under
or it's like section one I believe
section one if a resident of New
Hampshire dies living in a state
entirely a personal property the total
value of which exclusive of tangible
personal property
of which decedent was owner so
so is this saying that we're excluding
the value of Real Estate
thank you representative for the
question it does not deal with real
estate if you if the deceased person
dies with real estate with or without a
will you've got to go through probate
this does not deal with real estate
thank you
other questions
I did just in terms of form it says here
that
the person that could
go forward with
litigating the estate is the surviving
spouse child grandchild parent brother
sister niece nephew aunt or uncle or any
interested party could it not just say
any interested party yes of course
but you know even though representative
Terry is not a lawyer I think he's
picked up lawyer things you know we get
paid by the word
so maybe that's why it says all that I
thought we got paid by the hour yes
any other questions
seeing none thank you for your testing
thank you commit uh committee members
judge king
good morning again Mr chairman members
of the committee my name is David King
I'm the administrative judge of the
circuit court and as I said have been
involved as a probate judge for 32 years
and have sat on thousands obviously of
cases over those 32 years and I'm here
just by way of information and raising
some concerns that I have when judicial
branch is not taking a position on this
bill but the conversation that's taken
place so far is has raised some good
questions and I'll I'll try to address
those as I go through
um I do want to clarify that New
Hampshire did have a small estate
Statute in the past it was twenty five
thousand dollars it was a statutory
scheme that was in place for a while and
it it didn't work and when it didn't
work we came back to the legislature and
we tried to fix it with summary
Administration which we have waiver of
administration and some shortcuts that
we've built into the statutes that I
think do a lot of what the
representatives want to do so I want to
clarify that if the if we have an estate
in New Hampshire that's under twenty
five thousand dollars there was no bond
required it's a pretty simplified
application process and those are turned
around pretty quickly in this bill they
talk about the Probate Court which
doesn't exist anymore and so I'm
assuming that the intent is that these
get filed in paper locally
our e-filing system is not configured to
take something like this on so I think
it would actually slow the process down
that would be one of my concerns there's
no requirement for an inventory so
how is the Probate Court going to know
if there's twenty five thousand dollars
or if there's a hundred and twenty five
thousand dollars what what commonly
happened when we had small Estates in
the past and one of the reasons that we
eliminated the statutory procedure was
a petition would come in with good
intentions that everyone expected that
there was this one ten thousand dollar
bank account and we would appoint an
administrator and they would now have
the authority to investigate and Marshal
the assets and pretty soon it's twenty
seven thousand dollars and they had to
start all over again and it was very
inefficient and that happened regularly
in this bill
I don't see any real mechanism for
creditors to be paid representative
Terry said it would be there would be a
month or two to pay creditors claims
right now creditors have six months to
make their claim and then a year to
perfect those claims I don't know if
this is meant to shortcut that or not
and I also don't see any notice
provision where creditors would even
know that the estate is open so I think
that the creditors might have potential
creditors might have concerns with this
process
currently if the estate's over ten
thousand dollars we require publication
which is a means of providing notice you
see the notices in the newspaper that
so-and-so has been appointed I've tried
to get that switched over to doing it
online but the newspapers want to keep
it in the newspaper so we haven't been
successful there
um
but it seems like there's no
accountability for the
administrator once they're appointed
they're off and running and they can do
what they want there's no scheme for
what also commonly happens which is
you've got a 25 000 estate but you've
got 35 000 worth of bills we have a
statutory scheme now that provides for
insolvent Estates it looks like from the
way I read this bill that the
administrator can kind of pick and
choose who gets paid
and I'm not sure that that is the scheme
that you want to have in place because
some creditors are likely to get nothing
and others may get paid 100 cents on the
dollar
the automobile is a good question that
has come up for years we do now have a
statute where if in the situation where
someone dies and the only asset is an
automobile
you can go to the town clerks and I just
did this with my mom my dad passed away
in in February and for some reason my
dad's had a vehicle in his name alone
and we went to the town clerk's office
took about five minutes and the title
was switched over into my mother's name
no reason to go to the probate court so
we've I think dealt with the automobile
issue
um
okay
I think those are the concerns that I
have there is there's apparently no
requirement for a final account so I'm
not sure
who if anyone gets noticed about where
the where the funds went
and there's no mention in the bill at
all about a situation where someone dies
with a will it talks only about
intestacy and it talks about the
distribution under intestacy I'm not
sure if this bill contemplates small
Estates where there's a will involved or
if those would go the normal route we do
have electronic filing for
self-represented filers which is about
half of our business it's a guided
interview much the same way
representative chase that the
guardianship is now and under 25 000
again no bond so I think and we do have
a waiver of administration so if it's in
that you legislatures um just expanded
that so for example
um everything to the wife that's a
waiver of administration there's no
account no inventory it's a much
simplified process so I think the
legislature's done a really good job of
streamlining the probate process already
and so before we go back to the small
Estates I would just ask you to consider
those things and I'd be happy to answer
any questions that you have
representative Chase
thank you Mr chair and thank you again
judge king for taking my question so my
my question is with the creditors when
my daughter passed away and my brother
um I had the bills that were due and I
just called the creditors and told them
that they had passed away some wanted to
have a copy of the death certificate but
no one asked to pay the balance they
just dissolved it now is that the normal
way these things go I mean I took it
upon myself to call creditors is that
you were saying that had accreditors may
not be even notified of a death
I'm just curious how it works for future
so you I mean you as an a relative in
Heir perhaps an air at law have no
obligation to call the creditors if
you're appointed as administrator or as
an executor then you do have an
obligation to marshally assets and pay
the creditors to the extent that you can
I do want to follow up on a question you
asked earlier representative chase that
I forgot to raise which is the situation
where your brother passed away and I'm
very sorry for your loss um
and it wasn't clear whether
he had 10 cents in his bank account or
ten thousand dollars and how do you go
about doing that we also have a
streamlined process for that with no fee
it's a one-page form we appoint you as
administrator to with the power to go
out and investigate what the assets are
so you take it to the bank and they you
know you can even get in the safe
deposit box the only thing you can take
possession of without a court order is
the will so if you go to the safe
deposit box and you find a will then you
can come back and open the estate but
you may find nothing
you can also open a Administration with
no filing fee with a very simplified
process to get medical records so
sometimes the family just want to find
out more about the death of a loved one
but there are no assets no filing fee we
give you the authority so the hospitals
will recognize it and you know maybe
there's an investigation of whether
there's been some malpractice or
something like that so that's commonly
used too
um so we don't make you pay and you
we have a form on our website that's
pretty
um easy to find that's a request to
waive the fee and I routinely waive fees
in Estates where there's not a lot of
assets certainly anything under a
thousand dollars if somebody asked me to
waive the fee I automatically do even
though that's Revenue out of the state's
pocket it seems like if it's a thousand
dollars we shouldn't be charging you 120
filing fee so
um
yeah
other questions
I just uh if I could just ask I think
the
uh the situation where you have a twenty
five thousand dollars or fifty thousand
dollars
uh and right now you're required to keep
the estate open for at least six months
for creditors to make their claims
there is a fairly typical situation
where people have
find a bank account after someone dies
with two thousand dollars in it or
they've shut off the electricity and the
elect and the electric company sends a
check after the fact for a refund for a
hundred and fifty dollars payable to the
person or the estate and you can't cash
it and people have to walk away because
it's
more expensive and time consuming to
take the money than it is to process it
is there any can you think of any means
or method that could expedite the
processing of those types of cases the
only thing I can say Mr chairman we I
certainly don't like it when I see those
cases
um is we waive the filing fee we make
the appointment quickly and
um
I mean I've even waived the requirement
of an inventory and account if that's
literally all there is and it's we know
where the money is going but the problem
again is when they think it's only that
one thing and then we make the
appointment and they realize there are
other assets and then there's no real
way to find out what's going on so I
think it's a little bit of a slippery
slope once you go there but I I agree
it's it's terrible when somebody has to
open an estate for 500 it is and I've
had people come in come and somebody
mentioned uh hearings there are no
hearings with appointments anymore there
used to be some judges routinely had
petitioners come in for a hearing the
only hearings we have with regard to
Estates now and it's about three percent
of the cases where there's some kind of
a dispute between heirs or who's going
to get appointed or things like that so
it's I think we've simplified it as much
as we can
leaving the Protections in place but I
clearly Mr Jim and there are very small
Estates that would be
nice to have some kind of a streamlined
process I just don't know how you
capture those that Minority of cases and
not the ones where you think it's small
and all of a sudden it's grown
and then even even in that situation
maybe it's 500 but maybe
um
there's a creditor that's owed money and
and they need to have an opportunity
even you know the mom and pop was only
owed 100 bucks but they should be able
to get paid if there's money there so I
guess that's my concern
any other questions
yes representative Kenny
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question um I might just
not be understanding so I'm sorry if you
already explained this
um but it sounds like your concern is
like slippery slope and it might
actually make it harder but we heard
from the prime sponsor that 34 other
states are making an applicable system
work so could you just explain maybe
what those states are doing differently
than this bill would do or speak to that
yeah I don't know because I don't have
the information about what states and
what they do we do not have the uniform
probate code so I'll start there that's
a decision that's been made over many uh
decades I guess we do have summary
Administration which is a word that was
mentioned a few times by the primary
sponsors summary Administration is where
the fiduciary has been appointed the
bills are paid and they just file a
one-page form that says the bills are
paid
and all of The Heirs at law or legatees
under the will assent they sign that
they give it to us and we close the
estate no need for any kind of an
accounting we get a lot of those waiver
of administration is even a more
simplified process and as I said this
legislature expanded that but
you know the funds are all going to a
child or children or a spouse they file
a petition they're appointed and then
after six months they file an affidavit
that says the bills are paid we close
the estate no inventory no account very
simple process and we got a lot of those
too so those were both legislative
initiatives that came about after we got
rid of the small Estates the 25 000 and
I think they're shortcuts that have
worked really well over time
any other questions
attorney Robert Wells
thank you committee for letting me speak
my name is Robert Wells I live in
Hopkinton New Hampshire I'm the senior
trust and State Attorney at the McLean
Middleton Law Firm I'm also a member of
a committee of approximately 40 trust
and estate practitioners which meet
regularly to review proposed legislation
and then work with the probate judges to
make sure that whatever is going to be
proposed is acceptable to them as well
as making it easier for us as
practitioners including trying to reduce
unnecessary cost
we have been very successful as judge
king has indicated with changes in the
legislature most recently in August of
this year where we expanded waiver of
administration including providing a
probate judge with the discretion to
waive Administration in a situation
where it is not necessary
having practice for over 50 years and
both just here in really in New
Hampshire I have seen needless to say
small Estates and larger States
I think we can be proud of what we have
done here we have protected creditors
many times the first thing a beneficiary
wants to know is when can they get their
money
and they don't understand the primary
responsibility of a fiduciary in the
first instance is to pay creditors
before you pay beneficiaries
judge king referenced notice to
creditors which is a critical Factor as
uh in the in the administration of any
estate
we have a duty under common law and
under case law to notify creditors and
if we fail to notify creditors then the
statute of limitations the six months
that judge king referred to no longer
applies and they can come in at a later
date for purposes of reopening an estate
and going against the fiduciary for
having failed to give them notice
uh the small estate legislation in front
of you to me does not work
I'm very concerned about the issue of
what we now have is a very simple
process with the electronic filing of
petitions for probate we send in
original wills and original death
certificates hard copy notices go out
from the probate court to all the
beneficiaries notice shows up in the
paper thanks to the Probate Court
providing that notice so creditors are
familiar with who the fiduciary is
including names and addresses so they
can contact them for purposes of any
claim which they want to make
so I think this bill is not a helpful
bill I think and in fact it's going to
be a regressive bill I I'm concerned
about what happens in a situation even
in the case of intestacy a lack of
notice we know sibling rivalry creates
many issues and sometimes siblings live
here and live elsewhere I see the small
estate being one where there could be
somewhat taking advantage of another
sibling or another member of the family
simply by not giving them notice so I'm
opposed to the bill and I would hope
that you would not pass it but I'm here
to answer any questions if you have them
questions for attorney Wells
seeing that I just I just want to follow
up on the question I asked judge king
and that's with regard to those very
small incidents where you find that two
thousand dollar account or
or somebody gets paid a check after
their demise and
and then it
it's not something that typically an
attorney would be involved in because
you can't afford to hire an attorney to
process it
so is it um
is that something that your committee
has looked at as a way of coming up with
some remedy to address those types of
issues
our committee really hasn't dealt with
that time of that
specific
type of refund many times what will
happen in a common situation where if
it's a husband and wife or the husband
has died and there's an only child and
there is a joint bank account many times
what we suggest is that before they
close out the joint bank account they
simply put that money in an envelope
with a deposit slip and send it in
because the bank doesn't know
necessarily that the person has passed
away and they're they have the funds in
that account which avoids the problem we
have that often with our nursing homes
which have refunds refunds commonly will
be paid to the estate of versus to an
individual
we sometimes in the more sophisticated
homes which have large amounts of money
coming back we ask that a trust be paid
versus the estate or the person who has
gone into that particular home can
specify he want his children to receive
the refund so there are ways of handling
that but not specifically to address the
500 one that you mentioned other than
judge king indicating that he uniformly
provides waivers in that situation
thank you
any other questions seeing them thank
you for your testimony today thank you
Mr chairman
and attorney lalagian
thank you for the record my name is
janellejian I'm an attorney representing
the state of New Hampshire Department of
Health and Human Services
the department does not take a position
on this bill but similar to what you've
heard we have concerns
my job at the department is general
counsel foreign manager of the Medicaid
estate Recovery Unit
on average over the last 16 years we
recover about 6.7 million dollars on
behalf of the taxpayers
this bill does have a number of problems
the department would remain a resource
should it would require amendments
should the committee decide that this
bill should go forward in order to work
from the Department's perspective
the concerns that I have are numerous it
proposes as you've heard a new process
that would take time for the court to
adopt to and for anybody practicing
probate law to adopt to but more
importantly this bill proposes a few
different things that are contrary to
other probate statutes
it doesn't provide the priority of who
can probate it just lists the number of
people it also more importantly from the
Department's perspective as a creditor
does not provide for the priority of
expenses in an estate that's similar to
the one that's already articulated in
RSA 55419
in that case the department does have a
priority over other creditors and has
had one for over 10 years now in this
state
should we go back to this old payment
of this old payment priority system it
would be a significant negative fiscal
impact on the state of New Hampshire
to the state general fund over a million
dollars a year
and that's just in what we recover for
the state general fund it would also
recover it would also
result in a negative fiscal impact to
the counties and we recover on behalf of
the counties in this state as well
um
I wanted to add a little bit more about
the six-month creditor period that is
very important for due process there is
actually U.S Supreme Court case that
says the minimum is six months
so we can't shorten that creditor
process without running a foul of
creditors due process rights
I do deal a lot with my counterparts in
all 50 states or with all in all 49
states with respect to a state recovery
and I am familiar with probate estate
work in the other states and I would
have to say that having been an attorney
in the state for coming up on 23 years
I think New Hampshire is very
Progressive in this area and I think
that we have a number as you've already
heard a number of ways for people to do
shortened pro-b for medical records as
you heard to figure out what's going on
with assets as you've heard for no fee
but we also have one and done forms for
other small probate processes as well
that are very unique
um
and that is not something that exists in
other states
other states do have these short
probates but routinely my counterparts
and Medicaid estate recovery run into
credit creditor notification problems in
those States
and what this unit what my unit does is
something that New Hampshire has done
since before Medicaid was enacted in the
early 60s
welfare recovery has been part of the
fabric of this state since the 1930s
and to introduce this bill now would be
as I mentioned a very significant
setback for the department and for the
taxpayers of this state
those protections are very important for
all creditors but for the Department
included and they're also important for
the other heirs because as you've also
heard from attorney Wells and judge king
you don't you cannot imagine the family
in fighting until you see it and live it
every single day one person gets gets
access to the money and poof they're
gone and I see that a lot I also see the
case where there's that one check that
comes in after the estate closes and
attorney Wells mentioned and I agree
that that check oftentimes just gets
deposited in the bank account and the
bank doesn't have a problem with it it's
not as big a problem as you would think
we can sit here anecdotally come up with
these things and maybe it's happened to
us and maybe it hasn't but on whole I do
this every single day all day long day
in and day out and I have for years I
don't see this as a I don't see it as a
very frequent event
so I rather than repeat everything else
you've already heard I think
procedurally this bill has some issues I
think there's a negative fiscal impact
the department would be more than happy
to be a resource should it go forward
because I do think it would require some
significant Amendment
thank you for your testimony questions
for attorney little agent
seeing them thank you thank you is there
anyone else who would like to be heard
with regard to house bill 1140.
seeing no one
clear the hearing closed
and we'll move on directly to our next
hearing which is House Bill 1389
establishing the Superior Court land use
review docket
I'll call upon the prime sponsor
representative Lynn to provide his
testimony and introduce the bill
this is 1389.
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Bob Lin I'm a rep
from Windham and just as a first point
on on the bill I I do have a proposed a
very slight change but I think an
important one and I have to thank
representative chip Kimball for bringing
this matter to my attention on the um on
the first page not the not the title
page but the first actual page of the
law in section uh proposed section 491
7B Roman numeral one on line nine
um the that's uh just picking up sort of
mids Midstream from the prior line it
says um
from decisions of local land use boards
including but not limited to
decisions of Municipal planning boards
zoning boards historic district
commissions and conservation commissions
a Conservation Commission shouldn't be
there that representative rep as
representative Kimball pointed out to me
conservation commissions do not have the
kind of authority of those other of
those other zoning boards planning
boards historic districts commissions
conservation commissions are established
under RSA
36a and their their responsibilities are
much different so in what I would
propose is to instead of saying
conservation commissions include to
change the language to read and local
governing bodies that is that is
language that is included in the
planning and zoning laws and it would it
would include for example uh decisions
of you know the local Board of Selectmen
or Board of Mayor and Alderman that is
that that is proper and I it was a
really good catch on the part of
Representative Kimball had a nice
discussion with him and I'm very glad
um that he that he caught that
um
the purpose uh uh Mr chairman of members
of the committee of establishing this uh
land use docket basically is is designed
to bring more efficiency to the land use
uh uh appeal and review process
this proposed bill is is taken in many
respects from uh the business Docket in
which it currently exists in the
superior court and has existed for more
than 10 years now uh really
um
very successfully I know that yesterday
this committee heard Bill's dealing with
the land use appeal board and um you you
may have questions frankly about the
issue of you know well we have a land
use appeals board and now we would have
this land use docket a couple of things
I I would point out first is that this
if this bill is approved
this bill has a a wider jurisdiction in
other words the the land use board Deals
Only with housing appeals and I think
there is also a provision in there that
says if there's a if there's a
development that includes both housing
and
you know as part of the housing some
kind of commercial development in other
words maybe it's you know the first
floor of a building is going to be
commercial and then there will be
apartments or Condominiums upstairs that
could be covered by the
um the land use board but something
that's purely a commercial development
would not would not be covered whereas
it would be covered uh by this and the
idea of of this is to establish a
specific docket where cases would go to
judges who have who would be appointed
with the expectation that they would do
you know mostly this kind of work have
an interest in doing this kind of work
and and uh because of their expert the
expertise that they have in the area and
would gain in the area
um they would be able to to handle the
work uh more efficiently
um it does set some time limits I think
that are reasonable I know that um Mr
head from the judicial branch is here
and obviously he may have some some more
detailed information on that I it's
clear to me that the judicial branch
will need some resources if we were if
we are uh if this bill goes forward and
I think that's that's uh entirely
reasonable
um and I'll let I'll let him address
that more specifically but I think that
um you know in the just as to use it go
back to the business Court dock it as an
example
um that uh has operated very
successfully we had uh judge McNamara
who many of you may know served as the
business court docket judge for really
for the entire he was the first one and
served for the entire time of his tenure
over 10 years as a business court docket
judge just an excellent jurist I think
very well respected uh you know
throughout the bar and the legal
Community just did an excellent job and
I'm sure that we would have the same
kind of thing uh kind of thing here with
whoever is appointed uh to the land you
stock it so I uh I think it's it's
something that's important and that
should be done and I and I guess the
other the other points that he sent that
some of you are may have questions about
you know well we have the land use board
and now we would have this special
docket why do we have sort of two
Avenues of appeal
there are none questions would be some
overlap but a bear in mind that that is
not at all unheard of we have had for
I bet you it's got to be 50 years and
with respect to uh uh
land land tax and land condemnation
matters we've had both the uh you if you
know if you're aggrieved by a taxing
decision or a condom condom condemnation
something like that you may appeal that
either to the board of tax and land
appeals or you may appeal it to the
superior court that system has existed
for a long time seems to work fine and I
I don't see any reason why this system
would not would not work fine so with
that
um I think that sort of summarizes my
testimony I'm happy to answer any
questions questions for representative
Lynn
representative wolfer uh thank you Mr
chairman thank you thank you for taking
my question so you're not suggesting
that we the docket would replace the
housing appeals board I am not I am not
suggesting that no
any other questions
representative Horrigan
thank you very much Mr chairman thank
you very much representative
representative Lynn
um are you um I guess you're envisioning
are you envisioning
appointing a current Superior Court
judge and re-uh reassigning him or her
to this docket or we're going to hire or
have the exact Council hire a new person
and if it's and for hiring a new person
um
how does that I believe
I believe in a budget trailer Bill we
set a a limit on the maximum number of
Superior Court judges we can have so
that count towards that maximum number
where would that be like in addition to
however many we're limited to now
and I well I think I I think this bill
envisions that there would be a new
appointment for someone to that docket
and whether
you know whether let's assume this bill
passed really quickly and there was
there was a an opening uh on the
superior court I suppose the governor
could nominate and the executive council
could confirm someone making it an
appointment to this docket I mean to the
the land you stock it my anticipation is
and I again I think Mr head may have
more to say about this that the
anticipation would be that there would
be another judge you know a new judge uh
authorized for this
um as was pointed out in in other
contexts I think particularly given the
really I think very you know detrimental
impact of the covid situation on the on
the particularly the trial courts the
superior court and the uh and the
Circuit Court I think you know to have
if we're going to add this uh this sort
of specialized docket I think that they
really do need more resources to uh to
be able to deal with it and so I I again
I'll let judge I let uh Mr head speak to
that but I think that that probably is
what is in anticipated and I think that
you know I would support that
thanks
representative Langley
thank you Mr Speaker good morning
representative thank you for taking my
question
if there was a situation where there was
conflict between the land review board a
decision made by that board and this
venue who would have the ultimate
Authority
I think both I mean ultimately I think
the the ultimate review would be at the
Supreme Court
so we'd have to go to another both both
of both the land use board
and the and this docket you know appeals
would be to the Supreme Court and again
the analogy would be to the board of tax
and land appeals and the superior court
that system has existed for you know for
a long time and those appeals both go to
the Supreme Court thank you
any other questions yeah representative
Chase
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I'm reading the
mythology in the back and it says the
new Associated Superior Court Justice
would be appointed so what's the
difference between an associate Superior
Court judge and a superior court judge
and aren't we short of Judges at this
point
I I think I mean I think all all of the
except for the Chief Justice of the
superior court I think the official
title really of all the Superior Court
judges is associate Justice and I think
if you the language in um
in this bill
as was the case with the business Court
although the judge you know a judge
would be appointed if this bill passed
to the land use docket
the judge would still be a regular
Superior Court judge in the sense that
um you know if if there were if there
were other cases that that you know
criminal cases or other civil cases that
you know had to have had to be heard
that judge would have the authority to
hear it just as judge McNamara you know
he didn't he did
he did the business court cases but he
also from time to time heard criminal
cases and other things and that's I
think the same as intended here thank
you that helps
representative Simpson did you have a
question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I just need a little bit of clarity
is the when you're referring to the land
use board the land review board the
housing appeals board are those all the
same thing are those three different
boards no they're they're different
things if I'm and I'm sorry if I've
confused you I apologize I don't have
deep
no no so so for for a long time and I I
you know I'm not sure when it was first
established but there's there has been a
board what's called a board of tax and
land appeals it doesn't hear you know
the appeals from like zoning or planning
decision but if you if for example you
know the local you get an assessment on
your property and you think it's too
high and you want to challenge it
under the law as it has existed for many
many years you have a choice you can
bring that appeal to What's called the
board of tax and land appeals
or you can bring it to the Superior
Court you have the choice to do that and
then in either case you know if you're
not happy with the decision you get from
the superior court or the board of tax
on land appeals you can appeal to the
Supreme Court this if this bill were
enacted
um it would have it would operate with
the with the land use appeals board in
the same way if you assuming that for
example you had a you uh there were you
were
um you were aggrieved by let's say a
local planning board decision and let's
assume it involved housing so that it
would be covered by it would be within
the jurisdiction of both entities you
would have the choice you could appeal
to the uh land use board uh
or you could decide to go to the
Superior Court it would be it would be
that you know your choice as the as the
appellant and then in either case if you
were not happy with what the board did
or what the Superior Court did you could
appeal to the Supreme Court
thank you
any other questions
thank you very much
attorney head
an attorney had you asked for five
minutes and we're running a little
behind so I'm going to hold you through
that
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Richard head I'm
the government Affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch we do not have a
policy position on this bill what's
being handed out is a proposed amendment
and it may also be since there's a
fiscal note it would be an amendment
dealt with with a finance committee but
IT addresses one of the questions that
came up earlier which is would a new
Justice need to be appointed and would
that change the total number of Judges
that are allowed by Statute currently
it's a chief justice and 21 associate
Justice or judges which is where that
naming comes from we would ask that that
number be increased from 21 to 22 and
that there also be an appropriation
because we're no longer we're not in a
budget year so there would have to be an
appropriation for the new judge or if if
it was the desire of the legislative
body then there would be a pause in
terms of starting up this docket we can
wait till the budget year comes into
effect and do the budgeting at that
point but one of the one of the sort of
key themes that we've seen in a number
of bills is the desire to have these
dockets go faster there are a lot of
timing issues associated with the
developments but these also tend to be
very complex dockets so they tend to
take a little bit of time for the judges
the parties and those that are
interested in these cases to get
involved and get all the evidence sort
of marshaled and before the judge they
tend to involve Experts of their complex
cases so they you know they can take
some significant amount of time if there
is a dedicated docket and there is a
dedicated judge that would be able to
that would be an additional judge it
would allow that judge to spend more
time on these cases to be able to focus
on these cases and to be able to get
them and resolve them in a more timely
manner
um with regard to the the split between
the existing sort of uh land appeals
board and this as Justice Lynn mentioned
you know that does happen both boards
are governed by the same rules that are
the same laws so they're they're
reviewing these projects based upon the
same underlying laws they're just doing
it through either less formal process
through the board or more formal process
with the superior court but if you if
you have a spiritual judge with a with a
docket of roughly you know 800 cases you
know land use docket case or a land use
case sort of gets mixed in with the
other cases if you do have a dedicated
docket you have a dedicated judge that
would help expedite some of the some of
those cases I mean with that I'd be
happy to take any questions
any questions
yes representative trottier thank you Mr
Speaker
thank you sir quick question on the
fiscal note I see that they're showing a
279 thousand dollar
um expense in 2023
and in 2024 that almost doubles and in
2025 it still increases whereas in the
note it says you know under that 279
there's a lot of
one-time expense which includes phones
I.T computers and things like that can
you explain why the big increase sure
thank you for the question the the
expectation was it was going to come
into effect halfway through a fiscal
year so it didn't account for a full
fiscal or a full fiscal year
okay thank you sir sure
any other questions
Mr chairman yes representative Lorenzo
thank you Mr chairman and hello again um
Mr head you know I'm having a hard time
sort of envisioning this post schematic
so would it be possible if
um the sponsor or yourself could send us
sort of like a diagram of you know how
this is going to work
I'd be happy to although I'm not sure it
would be a very simple diagram you have
so for example a planning board makes a
decision
there are a number of potential parties
who could be appealing that if there was
a butter that was unhappy with the
decision or the developer who was
unhappy with the decision by Statute and
currently exists by Statute that
um
that appealing party has to decide
whether or not who has jurisdiction to
hear the appeal if it's a commercial
development it has to go to Superior
Court if it is a housing project that
party would have it have the decision to
decide whether they're going to go to
the land use appeals board or to
Superior Court and that's pretty much
the only thing where where it sort of
splits and then from either one of those
there's an appeal to the Supreme Court
if it is from the land use appeals board
did they make a decision that somebody
wants to appeal it's a discretionary
appeal to the Supreme Court so the
Supreme Court may or may not take that
appeal if it's a superior court decision
it's a mandatory appeal to the Supreme
Court and the Supreme Court at that
point does have to take that appeal
and sort of that's the the lineup it's
not a it probably wouldn't be a very I
don't know the diagram would help a lot
because it's going to be basically two
lines going up
I think it would be helpful okay I mean
just listening to you explain it I mean
I got kind of lost halfway through it
fair enough I'm happy to work with with
representative Lynn and have something
presented thank you so much okay sure
representative Horrigan
thank you very much Mr chair thank you
much attorney ahead um
I'm inferring that the Assumption that's
halfway through the fiscal year is
because of the uh rather simple fact
which that the bill doesn't take effort
back to January 1st 2023 so uh which
will be assuming this gets to this
committee and all the other people
against the governor's desk and he signs
it um
um he probably wouldn't sign it until
you know June or July anyway so
um
will will the governor be able to the uh
Superior and the Chief Justice Superior
Court be able to start recruiting a
candidate for this post and submit the
name to the council
before January 1st are they gonna have
to wait till January 1st of 2023 to
start the whole process going I I think
there's there's the the fiscal note
which sort of has a mechanical process I
think as a practical matter it probably
wouldn't start on January 1 it would
start some period of time after so that
first you know in the partial fiscal
year it probably is a practical matter
wouldn't even start till the beginning
of fiscal year 2024
um notwithstanding the effective date
which also goes to you know the the
phrasing in the bill is
um that the uh
Supreme Court May establish the court
it's really a process that has to go
through the the Chief Justice the
Supreme Court and then ultimately the
the assuming that the court wanted the
docket and created the docket there
would have to be the appointment and the
rest of it so as a practical matter no
it's not going to start on January 1.
yes uh my question uh is I I don't
really have any doubt that
it would be an improvement in the way
that land use cases are being held
I think the the issue I'm having is with
the Superior Court
and
the fact they're not even having trials
this month
and they are delayed in the manner in
which they're handling lots of different
types of cases not just land use cases
and the question I have if
is I think and the the only really issue
I have with the bill
is
if the superior court is going to be
given half a million dollars
what would its priority be would it be a
land use court or is there some other
priority I well I thank you for the
question I think it's fair to say that
you know the legislative intent is to
create a if the if the legislature were
to pass this that this judge be
dedicated to the land docket so the in
the first instance it's the land docket
if
if by chance there's free time they
might take another case or two in in
non-land uh Appeals
but I think as a as sort of the the
commercial docket that was set up sort
of demonstrated judge uh uh the the
currently a different judge but the the
judges that have been appointed to that
position have taken as a priority those
those cases
you could read and you could write into
the law that this would be the priority
of the judge but I think as a practical
matter the purpose of setting up the
docket would be to to do that and not to
say great we have a new judge they're
not going to spend any time on the land
and the land appeals they're going to
spend it on civil cases
um I I think the purpose of the
legislation would be followed
any other questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
Mr chairman
and we have one other person
and that's Greg Moore
good morning Mr chairman members and Mr
Moore
oh sorry better thank you for the record
my name is Greg Moore I'm the state
director with Americans for Prosperity
here in New Hampshire and I find myself
in the unusual if not rare position
coming to the legislature to advocate
for growing government but I think that
this is important this is uh definitely
an area where our state is being held
back by the lack of of our ability to
quickly move on a lot of these issues
relative to land use issues
if you look I had a chance to talk to
several land use attorneys I actually
encourage them to come in today as it
turns out they were busy doing attorney
stuff but uh but uh what you what you
hear is is if you bring in a land use
case to Superior Court it will often
take a year and a half before you
actually get into court and oftentimes
as long as three years before you get a
final decision which means that
it's it's a practical reality I mean it
is a is a legal rally but it's not a
practical reality you can't actually get
Justice if you have to wait three years
if you're a developer your financing
can't hold on for three years if you're
an individual who has an issue with a if
you're in a butter and you have an issue
is it worth the three years and the
legal cost to go that are associated
with this so this for is a great way for
individuals to have a quick expeditious
venue to get resolution on on land use
issues I think the timelines are are
extraordinary I think it's it's the
ability to get in and out of court in a
matter of five months would be in an
extraordinary Improvement uh for for a
lot of those a lot of folks who have
that opportunity
and frankly we have a number of of towns
that are making this land use decisions
uh that that frankly need to be need to
have the opportunity for quick judicial
review I'm going to quote from um
Cordell Johnson who's the governor of
Affairs Council from the New Hampshire
Municipal Association he said he was
talking specifically about another bill
legislation relative to Second Amendment
issues and towns enacting restrictions
relative to Second Amendment issues but
talking about how these Town officials
are volunteers and that's absolutely
true you know our town government's work
on the basis of volunteers they wouldn't
work without a lot of committed people
dedicating their time
but he said with rare exceptions they're
not legal experts they're not lawyers
and they're not intimately familiar with
the limits of town Authority and so
towns inadvertently pass ordinances all
the time that may not be within their
Authority so we have local officials who
are overstepping their Authority
but if you want to challenge that you
don't have a practical remedy to be able
to get into court and get quick
resolution and so uh House Bill 1389
helps resolve that problem I think one
of the one so the the speed with which
is is a huge Improvement I think the
other huge advantage and I think the
sponsor touched on it is that if you
have one Justice handling all these
cases as opposed to 20 21 22 justices
taking up land use cases you're going to
very
quickly and and get a very clear body of
case law that will help all these Town
officials make these decisions going
forward because you're going to have
you're going to have consistency as so
you have one judge ruling over and over
again on these types of issues the state
will will uh will very quickly have a
clear sense of understanding of you know
what's inbounds what's out of bounds and
that will help actually the local zoning
and planning boards I know that I know
that we've been finding workarounds for
this issue I I think the housing appeals
board is a workaround for the fact you
couldn't get quick resolution I know
representative Alexander put legislation
in last year to mandate legal training
for for uh legal training for zoning and
planning officials I think this is a
better solution it's a better solution
it gets us to to where we want to be
quickly as far as the volume of work I I
don't know I suspect that if there was
the opportunity for quick resolution you
would see more volume because I think
there are a lot of people who simply
won't go to court because of the delays
and cost associated with trying to get a
resolution through the superior court I
think that this you would quickly see a
higher degree of volume but I think that
as as I mentioned as there's a body of
case law that is quickly established I
think that volume would end up dropping
over the long term so uh I know you guys
are behind schedule so I don't want to
take any more time testifying so with
that I'd be happy to take any questions
okay
questions for Mr Moore
seeing none thank you for your time
thank you
is there
is there anyone else would like to
testify on House Bill 1389.
seeing no one we will close the hearing
on House Bill 1389.
and we will take a eight-minute recess
to give everybody an opportunity to uh
a brief opportunity to do what they need
to do
yep
I tried to do
no I did
yeah yeah
that I could
have been yesterday
just keep saying
foreign
thank you
we'll call the house Judiciary Committee
back to order
our next item of business today today is
a hearing on House Bill 1592.
the primary sponsor is representative
gay and representative gay would you
like to introduce your bill
thank you Mr chairman
um
we after reviewing the bill after it was
finished was it was pointed out that
there were a lot of
ways it could be simplified so that's
why I've handed out the amended version
everybody already has one
okay I'll just read it real quickly it's
very short recordings of proceedings
each party to a proceeding and family
court shall have the right
each party till proceeding in a court in
a family court shall have the right to
make their own recordings of the
proceedings for comparison to the
official court recording each recording
by the party shall be accompanied by a
document that identifies at what point
the party's recording differs from the
official court recording and shall be
admissible along with the official court
recording in an appeal where the
proceeding is relevant
the reason for this this bill is
apparently awkward the reason the need
for this bill
is prompted by several people who have
told me that when they
purchased
their copy
of their proceedings the official
recording an official transcript there
were several things missing
well if they can't make their own
recording they can't prove it
so this way we don't change the law you
still have to if you file an appeal you
still have to submit the official
recording but if there's a difference
you get to submit you're a recording too
with a documentation that says where
they differ we don't expect people in
court to have to spend hours looking for
some kind of discrepancy
your questions will be helpful
any any questions for representative gay
representative Chase thank you
thank you thank you representative gay
for taking my question
I don't this just doesn't seem like um
the right thing that you'd be able to do
is just to record yourself why would
why would these people feel that
something was taken out of the
transcripts because they have a memory
I don't mean to sound flippant but I
mean when when somebody when somebody in
an authority says something to you that
sounds off
you have no recourse
to show that it happened unless you have
a record
represent Chase so what you're saying is
in the instances that have been brought
to you when they did get the recorded
piece that that flip remark or whatever
was taken out so they they don't have
any way of tracking it
yes and they said that you can hear the
clicks we used to have court
stenographers
but now
I'm told but I I can't swear to this
that the judge actually has a has a
button that he turns it off and on and
when they get the recordings and even
the transcripts show there's clicks
and it'll even say it in the transcript
thank you very much thank you
any other questions for representative
gay
representative Horrigan well this is
more more question of the chair which is
um
we're although they're not directly
related to the issue they cited several
family law cases and one of them uh
Campbell versus Bush's partello Campbell
was a friend of mine I served with him
in the legislature and I have a
discussed what's going on with himself
and his lawyers I mean I don't think
that's I mean I don't think I think I
can still like consider this film
partially if I just thought I'd draw
that attention to you and think there's
if you think that might color the
objectivity of these proceedings but uh
I mean and either Campbell nor Campbell
is definitely not here today I don't
wouldn't recognize partello if she
showed up and that's probably these are
probably just be excited as examples of
why this bill is needed more than uh
and they're kind of tangential to the
substance of the bills
just thought I'd Express I I see that I
do have a concern here and I I
think you've done the the appropriate
Thing by making a disclosure to it if
you feel that you have a conflict then
you will need to fill out a form yes as
provided by the ethics guidelines okay
but if you do not feel you have a
conflict of course you don't have to do
it but I think I'm okay but I just have
a little bit of a doubt and I thought
I'd just thought I'd let you know about
this I think uh the Disco disclosure is
appropriate and thank you very much okay
thanks
and Ms partello is here today
and in fact I will call Ms partello as
our next witness thank you
representative thank you
good morning thank you for the
opportunity to allow me to testify
before you
um my name is Robin partello and I'm a
resident of Nashua New Hampshire
and
to speak first about the recusal if
there's a question of any conflict of
interest I think the best course of
conduct would be to recuse yourself from
um
this situation but that is ultimately
the decision of this panel and I'll
respect whatever decision should be made
I'm here testifying in support of House
Bill 1592 former judge Julian tricasso
altered my official court record in the
Nashua Family Division she was
eventually removed by the judicial
conduct committee and charged criminally
by the New Hampshire Attorney General's
office
House Bill 1592 would bolster
accountability within the court system
to preserve records into a short ensure
accountability
at this point I would welcome any
questions if anybody should have any
are there any questions for MS partello
representative Kenny
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question
um could you just explain because it
seems like the judge that altered it was
held accountable so what this bill would
do differently
um well
the judge what had happened was that the
judge appointed her best friend Kathleen
Sternberg as a gal in my in my case and
six months into it judge intercasso
finally admitted that the guardian ad
litem Kathleen Sternberg was her best
friend Kathleen sternerberg at all
junctures was not honest regarding my
payments So eventually I said I want to
send you an electronic payment
she said I do not accept electronic
payments I only accept cash or checks
so I said
this is the 21st century you know you
should accept electronic payments she
doesn't have an office I can't mail cash
to her so she said
I'll file a motion with the court and I
said okay you know the court is
impartial and you know Julian tricasso
her best friend ruled on it and said
that I had to pay in cash or money order
and then subsequently disclose the
conflict
so at this point I filed a complaint
with the judicial conduct committee and
at this point Julian tricasso took my
file into her office and Whited out the
handwritten portion of where she told me
that
um Kathleen Sternberg should be paid by
cash or or check
she also went on to blame me for this
when she was investigated by the
judicial conduct committee which was a
slap in the face because that is not
something I would ever do and then she
blamed the court staff
so to answer your question I believe
that if the judges know that they are
accountable and they are not able to
alter court records in any capacity I
think it would
ensure accountability and a generalized
oversight for the judges because you'll
hear other testimony behind me today
where judges or the transcripts were
actually altered and you know there were
items taken out and the process is when
we as a litigant in the court system
want to get our transcript we send a way
for it to a company in Arizona and they
provide us with a written transcript
which looks something like this and it's
official court document so something
like this costs about fifteen hundred
dollars to order and
as litigant you assume that everything
in this transcript is accurate right
well we're finding it's not the judges
have discretion to stop the recording
you know and they're being altered so
we're forced to get
the CD and listen to the actual audio
and then go line by line and compare it
to this which isn't fair so if we had
the opportunity to record we could get a
sense of confidence that we know that
everything in here is accurate without
you know having to double check the
Judiciary which is something quite
frankly I don't think that litigants
should be responsible to ensure that the
Judiciary is being honest and ethical
thank you so much you're welcome
are there any other questions from MS
partello
thank you for your testing thank you
very much
Vivian Gerard
what's that
chair of woman and members of the
children and family committee thank you
for allowing me to testify here today
again my name is Vivian Gerard and I'm
the mother of two daughters one 13 and
115. I live in Hollis New Hampshire and
I am a business owner of Timber post bed
and breakfast
I am here testifying in support of Bill
hb1592
and as a self-employed single mother it
can sometimes be tough to make ends meet
I've had extensive legal bills totaling
280 thousand dollars
and a lot of this does go back to
getting all the transcripts that I've
had to request
I am the Silva V Silva case that
supports the RSA 458
um that has been up to the New Hampshire
Supreme Court four times
the docket number is
2016-0478
2017-06.0063
2019-0390 in
2020-0152 so every time I went to the
Supreme Court it they ruled and it was
vacated back to the local Court
so far over seven years of my life
has been given to this court system I've
had 20 trial court hearings
many before former judge Julie and
decasso as well as master Bruce delbra
I also have another hearing with oral
arguments
um on 10 26 had I should say had um or
arguments on 10 6 26 2017 that was
before The Supreme Court I had yet
another trial court date that was that
may be rescheduled on January 18th which
is next week because I need to be here
to testify
at twenty dollars twenty five dollars
per audio
from the court that's about 550 dollars
right there
just for the audio
and I'm not presently even allowing
allowed to record myself
so even if it's not needed for any
appeal maybe a party or attorney just
wanted it for their own records to go
back on
it's the party's own recorded is
certainly not fair it's not good enough
for that
um even if you don't know what these
transcripts cost
let me tell you they're very expensive
they're at least three dollars a page
and when you have as many as I've had it
gets very very expensive
in my case in Picasso also said that I'm
glad that you're trying to live the
All-American dream but go out and get a
real job
and she clicked that off of the audio
when I went back with my attorney at the
time
to get the audio it was gone because she
said that I should shut down my business
and within six months and if I did not
she was going to take away all child
support and all alimony
and to me that's just not okay it's it's
part of the New Hampshire state law that
when families separate both parents have
an obligation to raise these children
uh the attorney like I said did ask for
the transcript which did not include
these condescending comments that was
actually stated from the judge that was
said in the hearing
uh being able to make my own proceedings
would allow me to hold the judge
accountable Through The JCC complaint
for example which I've done not only
with intercostal but I also did it with
delpra
um unfortunately I've had three bad
judges on my case so I go from one bad
decision to the next to the next I have
no way to independently confirm these
statements from the court that the data
except the testimony from my former
attorney who requested the transcript
he can confirm it was not on there but
recently when I went to Bruce delpra I
got the audio and he did specifically
say that I was
a thorn in his side
he also said that he was the blessed one
to hear my case
and he also said that he didn't want to
reopen a can of worms and that can of
worms was my reman that came back from
the Supreme Court that should have fixed
my problems and this dated back to 2018
I would have been out of the system
but again because we didn't have these
audios until recently or didn't know
that there was a problem with this
what do you do
so when I ordered my official audio and
transcripts on 12 13 of 21 from the
national Family Court from my last three
hearings it was 75 dollars to prepare
for my upcoming hearing on the 18th of
next week
um it took the trial court until 1224 of
this year to get my audio so the day I
found out from Tim gutis of the Supreme
Court that I had a hearing on January
18th myself and one of my friends went
on and we ordered the transcripts
immediately
to get them on time
I have to push out my court date next
week because I don't have those
transcripts
so it's two weeks after the need date
to even get an official audio from me in
each escribers is causing me not to have
the transcripts ready before this date
so as you can see it's a real problem
here
in the current system compels a party
wanted or need in a transcript
transcript to engage in Commerce with
the private for-profit company and we're
forced to pay these bills
and what company charges whatever the
company charges we have no
say we need the transcript in order to
go fight your battle in court
and when you're making you can't even
afford to make ends meet you're dumping
all these thousands of dollars on each
audio and transcript
and let me remind you again that I had
22 herons
and I ended up going to the Supreme
Court four times
nothing in this bill prevents any party
from getting audio and transcripts
through e-scribers or CD from the court
like they've always done
we just need to have the ability to have
some completion in in this business and
some more options for parties on a
budget
or who need a same-day recording of the
trial is unable to provide
but they could just record them
themselves
so I'd be happy to take any further
questions or comments
are there questions
sorry thank you so if you this went
through you're able to anybody can now
record would you
do it on your phone would you bring in a
an actual
recording device I mean to make sure
it's official yep the way I would do it
now just because everybody's leaning
towards on technology that they always
have everybody always has their cell
phone on them
um I would have probably done it through
my cell phone just so I have that audio
and that could be uploaded to the
computer
at least it would be accurate
any other questions
thank you for your testimony today thank
you very much
Dana Albrecht
I don't know if I'm pronouncing that
correctly yes
thank you Mr chairman my name is Dana
Albrecht and I'm a resident of Nashua
New Hampshire
some of you might have already heard
about my family law case which has
received news coverage
several times in the New Hampshire union
leader as well as national news coverage
in The Daily Beast and about which I
testified before house children and
family law committee two days ago in
support of HB 32
obviously today I'm here to testify in
support of HB 1592
uh
to allow parties to make recordings of
their own hearings I have provided the
committee with three exhibits
um those are not my testimony that
simply evidence and support of some of
the things I'm testifying to
um
so first I'd like to point out that this
bill helps to address what has been an
ongoing problem for nearly 40 years
and that it concerns both state and
federal due process rights and there's a
couple
decisions from both our New Hampshire
Supreme Court and the first circuit
federal court of appeals that I think
are pretty relevant
to the committee reviewing this bill
and those are an exhibit one which is
Whit fee justices of New Hampshire
Superior Court
from the court of appeals Federal
and uh
confirth of econforth which is a state
supreme court decision again you can
look at those later I just think they're
relevant
so uh
wit in like a federal due process
addresses how a New Hampshire family
court judge
is supposed to review the
recommendations of a marital master and
what sort of the record is supposed to
look like and I think this bill really
is speaking about what the record is
and that federal case in turn cites
conferth which is a 1983 family court
case that was Tried by
uh marital master Bruce dalpra and the
key there in that case is no recording
or stenographic record was ever made at
all
so I think that's a problem
and I'm going to essentially present an
argument to you that this is
not a one-time incident it's an ongoing
problem since then starting 40 years ago
uh
so
I think
my question to the committee is does
anyone
almost rhetorically care that we don't
even have
audio at all in some of these cases
um
and you know mastered out Prof from corn
forth 40 years ago no audio fast forward
today he's my marital Master judge in my
case
and uh his attitude on the record is who
gives an F concerning my testimony and
that was missing from the transcript
um
so I'd like to also argue that
again not isolated incidents that's a
key point
so I'm also one of nine family law cases
in which former judge Julian tricasso
appointed her best friend Kathleen
sternenberg is Guardian Ad Litem uh you
heard testimony from Robin earlier on
that
um
if the
uh I would refer the committee to
exhibit to
which contains a list of those nine
family law cases with case names and
docket numbers
again you can look at it later
uh and some correspondence from the
clerk of the court
concerning some of those
again to support what I'm I'm telling
you
um so I've requested audio recordings
from the court hearings of several of
these
cases
and in two of them there's been several
hearings where once again there's no
audio available from the trial court
hearing at all
so we're not even talking comparison
we're talking missing
and I think that's particularly
disturbing in the Sobel case
uh because once again that's a final
hearing before Master Dal pra Kathleen
sternenberg was there and where's the
audio
does anyone care
and again in support of what I'm saying
that just please you can look at the
letters from clerk Sherry bison in
exhibit 2. you know confirming that they
don't have it
um
so in my own case before the New
Hampshire Supreme Court
uh
pretty much the critical issue in the
case so far
uh was that the official transcript
admitted key portions of the audio
uh
and
that was crucial to the Supreme Court's
resulting decision to vacate
and remand
and we had to go back to East scribers
and we had to go back and we had to
compare all this stuff to figure out
discrepancies that was the issue one of
the key issues before The Supreme Court
um so
I realized there's an amendment today a
revised version but
the point about poor quality recordings
are non-professional creative
transcripts to be submitted to the
record on a PL I kind of think that's a
red herring in light of the amendment
what we're really talking about is the
ability of parties just to make their
own stuff in case they feel there's an
issue with the official stuff
um
and again you know why should escribers
have a monopoly I paid them almost eight
hundred dollars
for
the transcript that left out the most
critical stuff
um
and again to Echo Vivian nothing in this
bill prevents any room we just can
continue to order audio and transcripts
from escribers the way we do but there's
no reason that we should be denied the
right to make their own recording
or denied the right to have
another transcription company
you know transcribe it if maybe we just
need something of lower quality super
fast I'll just close with one example I
had a telephonic hearing two days ago
I'm still waiting on the audio I'm still
waiting on the official transcript sure
I want it from escribe or sure I want it
official from the court but it sure
would have been helpful to just hit
record on my phone and send it off to
speech pad and have something good
enough just for me
you know 12 24 hours later
um so uh thank you for your time and at
this point I'd like to answer any
questions
are there questions for strawberry
I think you did a thorough job with your
testimony thank you thank you sir
attorney head
thank you Mr chairman thank you members
of the committee my name is Richard head
I'm the government Affairs coordinator
for the judicial branch
um
I haven't actually seen
um representative Gay's amendment I just
heard about her talk about it today
which helped at least clarify what she
was intending with this bill
there there are a number of of different
points of views and things that were
were described and thank you
representative
um that were described in in the
testimony today some of them dealt with
a judge judge intercasso who was
convicted of of criminal wrongdoing she
was brought before the judicial conduct
committee and she is no longer a judge
I'm not she did bad things I met with
some of the clerks you heard Miss
partello talk about who were also
accused of of modifying documents those
are written documents
um and I I understand sort of how she
felt about it by having also spoken with
those clerks I'm not trying to in any
way talk about those types of of
incidents what we're talking about here
is what is the erector and what is the
official record when you go on appeal
and those are governed by court rules
and the Supreme Court has rules as to
what is the record that is before The
Supreme Court and that involves a
transcript and the transcript process
and and you were you that was accurately
described to you is
um when you file a notice of appeal part
of that is an estimate of what is the
cost of the transcript uh the state has
a contract with a company called
escribers and the official recording is
sent to escribers for transcription
process I've used multiple times in in
cases that I've appealed
um and and I also
at one point over last summer I did a
comparison of the cost that we incur for
transcriptions the cost of
transcriptions for appeals because again
the record on appeal is the transcript
not the audio recording absent some
unusual circumstance in our cost of
transcripts are either cheaper or
Incredibly Close to the costs of
transcripts and all of the other New
England states it's it not exactly in
Apples to Apples comparison because the
turnaround time in the cost is is a
little bit variable the faster the
turnaround time the higher the cost but
at least our costs of transcripts are
comparable to those around in the New
England states
what we're talking about here and is is
both the original bill in which the
audio recording would become the record
for appeal and then in the amendment
um from representative gay would be to
allow the parties to record to sort of
confirm the the transcript
and at least that makes a little bit
more sense than the original because if
we have for example you know you can
have a multi-day hearing and Family
Division and you know you would be
sending up to the to the justices you
know four days of audio recordings to
try to figure out what was the key point
that they're trying to get to or if a
particular point of in time in the
recording is identified by the parties
the justices still look at the entire
record because they need to be able to
put that into the proper context to
determine you know what is what is what
they're being directed at is it in fact
consistent with the rest of the record
or whatever the Appellate issue may be
and that is done and it has been done
for for uh
it it's always been done in terms of the
written transcript and the written
written record below and that is
established by Court rule if there is a
desire to change what is the official
record that should really be done by a
Court rule and there is a rules
committee and there's a member of the
the court rules committee and there's a
member of the House of Representatives
on that committee and there's a member
member of the state senate on that
committee and really those types of
things as to what is the official record
should be done by rule not by a statute
because it ultimately takes into account
a a wide variety of concerns and issues
so you know in terms of identifying and
determining what the record is I would
suggest that the the proper process is
through the through the court rules and
if somebody has a specific idea or issue
present that idea or issue to the rules
committee that could be then adopted as
as an official rule
the the issue of
to take another step back though is is
when we're talking about quote unquote
Family Court Family Court doesn't
actually exist now we're talking about a
division of the Circuit Court Family
Division
and Family Division does not have with
very few exceptions dedicated judges so
you have family judges that are also
hearing criminal cases that are also
hearing civil cases that are hearing a
whole host of of cases roughly about 125
000 cases a year
um in some budget cutting moves that
were made a number of years ago of Court
monitors were eliminated from the
Circuit Court in Superior Court we still
have court monitors they operate the
equipment they manage the equipment in
Circuit Court we do not currently have
court monitors so as you heard in the
testimony which was accurate the judges
are turning on and off the equipment
you have
and I'm not questioning this happens
um
I won't go to the intent of any judge
especially judging tricasso I will say
though that obviously mistakes get made
because you have a judge who has a room
full of of parties the judge has papers
coming in and out they're signing orders
they're doing a lot of stuff sometimes
that button does not get hit I don't I
don't question that Court monitors would
eliminate that issue it is a cost though
in a cost cutting
effort eliminated those in the past
bringing those back certainly brings a
professionalism and a stability uh to
that position and and ensures that
somebody is dedicated to that purpose
and that may help create more accurate
more complete audio recordings which
would then be what e-scribers is relying
upon
as to the goal that they're talking
about in terms of in the amendment that
was presented today
again that makes a little more sense
I've certainly had instances in which
I've received an e-transcript or a
triber subscriber transcript in which
they said something was unintelligible I
thought it was intelligible
um and uh and I had the recording and I
had the transcript and I filed a motion
I said I think this actually is and
here's the recording here's the point in
time
judges don't love that
um but I've also been able to work with
transcription services to say hey can
you go back you know this is this is
what I hear can you re-listen to this
particular point in time because again
they're doing the whole transcript if
you can focus them back where they said
unintelligible sometimes you can get
them to re-listen but these are
certified transcribers they have their
own professional ethics they have their
own duties as to sort of what they can
put into the transcript or what they
determine to be unintelligible and that
ultimately becomes the official record
the idea of of being able to compare
makes more sense if that self-recorded
on the phone thing is not the official
record but is for the parties to be able
to then compare to what is the official
record there is a process currently for
seeking permission to record in a
courtroom and there is a a form that can
be filed and and recordings can be made
with permission currently but again if
there should be a rule change my
suggestion is it's not best handled
through legislation but handled through
the rules committee and those can be
brought forward by the representative
member who is representative Birch or
through the senator Senate member
Senator Susie in those ideas and those
issues can be presented I will not say
that these records are without failures
at times certainly it happens and that
can be problematic in terms of what is
the official record when it goes to the
Supreme Court
but that said
I think it creates significant problems
where you have
litigant managed recordings being done
in a on a telephone that somehow becomes
the official record I think that's just
one not practical two can itself lead to
abuse and and three is really not the
proper procedure for determining what is
the official record and thank you Mr
chairman I'd be happy to answer any
questions
yes representative Chase thank you very
much thanks for taking my question so
you mentioned that there is an option to
seek permission to make recordings why
what is that procedure and why aren't
people doing that and I would be afraid
if I were we were allowed to record and
you're in a family courtroom type of
setting that anybody could be recording
you you're not there by yourself there's
other people waiting in the galley and
that's that's clearly part of the
problem in some of the issues that
especially in in Family Division where
you have some very personal very
sensitive things that are being said and
that recording is not in the Court's
control so it gets posted on the
internet you know who's recording what
is being recorded is it being recorded
just you know what's at the table or are
you also hearing what's going on behind
you you know we do not have control over
those recordings and at that point it is
for the individual who did the recording
to do with it as they wish so in Family
Division it is a more limited ability to
to make personal recordings I don't
question that and I don't know that that
is for a good reason because of the just
the very nature of what is frequently
being said in those in those proceedings
but you also then have the sort of
secondary issue of is it picking up
conversations that are going on around
that person who is recording and those
people are unaware that they're being
recorded so certainly a whole host of
potential unintended consequences from
from doing that sort of thing thank you
for the question
yes representative Chase I'm sorry but
the other part of it what you said
there's an option to seek permission to
make recordings what is that how what
does that entail and how easy would it
be for someone knowing that they're
having a hearing knowing they've had an
issue just to ask for that permission
just I've never actually done it it's
typically used and I'll take a step back
it is it's primarily there for media
because these are public proceedings the
media wants to have a recording so I
will say that's sort of the reason why
it went up but
um but there's nothing that prohibits a
party from making a motion to uh to ask
for a recording but again in these
contexts it is not necessarily
unreasonable for a judge to deny that
that type of request given the nature of
the proceedings
it
any other questions
it it seems to me that there are really
two parts to the issue here one is the
ability of at least a party to be able
to make a recording of the proceeding
and the other part is
the ability to use that recording as
evidence and some further proceeding I
think that's right and that's sort of
the split between the bill as presented
and the and the amended version from
from representative gay and so I guess
uh
my
and perhaps and
you've acknowledged and frankly it's my
experience as well that there are
circumstances where recordings aren't
made or even when they are made they're
intelligible and
why why would it be
offensive to not necessarily allow
everyone in the courtroom but allow at
least a party to be able to record the
proceedings so that they would have
something that would be an accurate
representation of what took place
I'm not saying it would be offensive uh
what what I I think the question is
what's the planned use of that and
how is the Integrity of that recording
itself being maintained
um
but I'm not denying there may not be a
process for for allowing for I'm not
sure
legislation of this type is is the
proper mechanism I think the better path
is to is to work within the the court
system and the Court rule process and
develop a procedure that protects the
interests of the parties protects the
interests of those who are in the
courtroom and uh protects the Integrity
of the record but as to the sort of over
overarching issue
if if you know
actually two other two other points one
is you know the court monitor issue is
is one of the things that would improve
the quality and the in ensuring a
complete record is is being recorded
um and then
I I guess that's that's primarily it
thank you
and uh and I I hate to dwell on it but
you've indicated it should be done
through the Court rule making process as
opposed to the legislature but
wouldn't someone have to in the court
rulemaking process be committed to do
that in order for that rule to happen
well I think I mean part of it I mean
right now I think there's nothing that
prohibits a party from making a motion I
think the court needing the judge
needing be able to one control what's
going on in the courtroom control sort
of
what is being recorded is an important
aspect of of ensuring that all of the
interests and rights of the the parties
the witnesses and those who are just
present in the courtroom are protected
but there's nothing I'm aware of nothing
maybe you're aware of anything of
something that would prohibit a party
from asking a judge and raising it with
the judge asking to record a procedure
I'm simply unaware of anything that
would prohibit that undercurrent under
current rules
so if if there have been instances where
in a particular case things have not
been recorded
um
I would make a motion and then I think
you get to the what you might hear is I
don't trust my judge I think my judge is
doing it deliberately
when I will take Judge Andrew Caso out
of the conversation we have incredibly
good judges we have incredibly dedicated
judges they are remarkably busy people
in terms of caseload stress load and and
the types of cases they're dealing with
and the types of parties they're dealing
with okay and and but I do think they
are fair and they want to do what's
helpful for the for the participants so
I would say current process allows for a
recording but it has to be done with
permission of the of the trial judge
thank you thank you
thank you for your testimony today
and
representative David love wishes to
testify
thank you Mr chair thank you committee
members for the record my name is
representative David love I represent
Rockingham six which is Derry and uh
I guess I can start out with one
statement as as uh as somebody that's
been abused by the family court here in
New Hampshire our family quotes are a
mess
okay uh for me um the the best thing we
could ever do
was really narrow down judicial
discretion and this is this this bill
here will stop that you know it'll it'll
it'll help to fix it when a judge can
sit there and say I don't want that to
be part of the record
okay and he holds his finger on the
button that's wrong you know people's
lives are at risk here
um you know kids lives are at risk look
at the mess these kids are today you
know drug abuse uh you know 12 and 13
year olds having sex uh you know failing
schools all the rest of it you know our
family quotes are a big part of that
you know and anything we can do
to make to set the record straight
because that's what we're doing if we
allow a judge to take put his finger on
that button that record isn't straight
anymore
you know we we have to
we have to put this this in because they
don't pay attention to rules they break
down but they have judicial discretion
you know I can break my own rules
you know the when the the gentleman
before me was talking I was thinking you
know all we're doing is asking the fox
to mind the hen house
you know we've got to stop that family
court is a mess you know they need
written
written laws written statute that they
have to go by or it's going to continue
and continue
you know my family's been up and been
victimized by uh you know the family
courts not just not not just my my
personal my brothers you know stuff like
that uh you know I I have one brother
that uh you know his third his 30 year
old son well you know when he was eight
or so uh went through this whole mess
and it was victimized by the family
courts a year ago he put a gun to his
head and blew his head off okay that's
where
not directly but certainly had a PL
played a pot
and that kid's suicide we've got to stop
this we've got to put some rules not not
rules we have to put some statue
together and make these judges follow
the statute
thank you
I'm sorry
we'll close the hearing on 1592.
and we'll begin the hearing on our final
bill for the morning which is house bill
1206.
and we'll call upon the prime sponsor
representative Lynn to provide his
testimony and introduce the Bill thank
you very much Mr chairman members of the
committee this really is a housekeeping
bill
and I in terms of sort of the substance
uh and and explanation for the reasons
of it I'm gonna I'm gonna defer to Mr
head from the judicial branch but
basically as you can see from the
language the purpose of of
the bill is just to make sure that the
costs for appointment of counsel and
Investigative Services
that are necessary uh for DNA testing um
are paid for by the judicial Council as
opposed to coming out of the funding of
the judicial branch I that's that would
you know that would to do that would be
consistent with the way those things are
handled in all other contexts and I
think it's it's uh it's pretty important
that that
um that they'd be handled that way with
respect to this legislation also and
that's really all I have to say I'm
happy to take any questions if if uh
Representatives have them
any any questions for representative
Lynn
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you very much thank you
and attorney head
thank you Mr chairman thank you members
of the committee my name is Richard head
I'm the government Affairs coordinator
for the judicial branch we had asked
representative Lin to present this bill
because last year
House Bill 270
pretty significantly expanded the rights
of parties who have been convicted of
crime to to file post-conviction DNA
testing petitions
and it included a provision to
um for Indigent parties to be to be have
their their
DNA petition Council funded by the state
normally as as representative Lin said
that's not done by the judicial branch
but without this correction that funding
mechanism is through the judicial branch
because there's another statute RSA 490
colon 31 that says if the funding source
is not clear the judicial branch is
responsible for uh for payment of any
costs that are ordered by the court and
since the the statute last year in house
built or the amendment last year in
House Bill 270 says that the court has
to provide Indigent defense counsel or
Indigent counsel for these post-dna
conviction petitions that became a
burden on on the judicial branch and and
really the intent is always that
Indigent defense fees are paid through
the judicial Council so this is as a
practical matter simply a a cleanup that
was missed in House Bill 270 last year
to to ensure that the the mechanisms
that already exist for Indigent defense
Council fees to be paid through the
judicial Council occur under this
statute also judicial Council we
consulted them with them with this
amendment and they also agree
that this was the intent and you
actually see in the fiscal note from the
judicial Council that it was their
assumption in in providing the fiscal
note that they would be responsible
for uh for the fees
and with that I'd be happy to take any
questions
any questions for attorney head
yes
oh representative D Lorenzo thank you Mr
chairman and attorney head I have a
question when I reviewed
um this bill
last night I noticed there was a range
in the amount of money that would be
available for the testing and I believe
it said somewhere between
five and ten thousand dollars was it
that's what the
so that that's the fiscal note from the
judicial Council so just in terms of of
structure to take a quick step back
judicial council is an executive branch
entity
and they manage the the costs and fees
of indigenous defense
um
why they put five to ten thousand
dollars in a year I don't know that
wasn't my fiscal note
um that was the judicial councils I see
um but that's just their estimate of the
cost of of DNA testing itself which
would if for an incident party be a be a
cost of the state
it's a wide variance it is it also you
know from what little I know about DNA
testing the type of DNA testing and the
quality of the DNA impact the price
um so it's it's not one one test one one
one DNA sample they're not all the same
okay thank you some are more complicated
some are more I see thank you very much
other questions
I think I had the same concern because I
I read that fiscal note that said it
would be five to ten thousand dollars
per test
and then the conclusion here is that
they couldn't calculate it was an
indeterminable amount it seems like
somebody could figure out how many tests
a year
we're doing well the the the the flip
side of that is the the bill last year
House Bill 270 expanded the
right to to perform post DNA testing so
we don't have a lot of history to fall
back on in order to
the expectation is there'll be more
filings
but because the bill has only recently
gone into effect sort of calculating
that in terms of number of cases and
types of DNA testing is is limited I
mean in the past we've gotten relatively
few of these
so the expectation is there'll be more
but how they how the judicial Council
itself sort of came up with that range I
don't know
but I suspect it just has to do with
with the nature of DNA testing which is
it's not
one test fits all
any other questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
I have no one else who signed up in
advance is there anyone else who would
like to testify on House Bill 1206
seeing no one declare the hearing closed
on House Bill 1206.
and recess for lunch we'll reconvene at
one o'clock
we'll call this meeting to of the
house Judiciary Committee to order
our first item of business this
afternoon is a hearing on House Bill
1086 relative to the concealment of a
cause of action and we'll call upon the
primary sponsor of that bill
representative of brahmi to introduce it
to the committee
well thank you Mr chair
um
for the record State Rep Pat abrami
Rockingham 19 stratum
I just want to point out to the members
that I put on
on there right before on front of their
spots uh handout so you should see that
and I'll be referring to that in a few
points
Michelle I'm here to introduce house
bill 1086.
relative to consuming of of course of
action
this bill was brought to my attention by
my constituent Brent arborghest
who will do a little more explanation of
this bill than I will
I uh I'm an engineer and I'm not a
lawyer
but in layman's terms what this bill
does
if you have a a wrong done to you and
the statute of limitations on filing a
suit has passed
but you discover a fraudulent
concealment
that you found later on that would want
you would then have reason to have cause
to uh to file a suit
had a
what would happen in this bill is that
the clock for the statute of limitations
would be reset
don't change the statute of limitations
to that particular type of of suit but
it resets the clock
uh to to that to that uh
when they when that's consumer was
discovered
a period of time the consumer occurred
shall not count and determining the time
limitation of of commencing the action
this bill does not change the statute of
limitation applicable for the particular
case type but changes when the clock
starts ticking
so an example would be
if there was such a limitations was five
years and then there was a discovery
that that they found that there was
fortunately concealment of of facts that
and you decide you want to file a case
that that after that two years
the clock zero and you get five years to
to deal with the case that you go on a
file
before before filing this bill I went to
the legislative research
who produced a list of states
that had fraudulent consumer laws
you will see 14 states have in the
handout that I presided 14 states that
fraudulent concealment laws
and actually one of them is New
Hampshire
on page eight
if you go to page eight of what I handed
out
uh
but that that fraudulent concealment law
is only for damages from construction
not all kinds of cases just Construction
so that's on page eight in the bottom
so the other of the 14 states there are
six that have complete uh fraudulent
concealment usually the states have
carve outs like we do
and that would be Massachusetts Vermont
Connecticut Missouri and Illinois and
Indiana
oh and you it's they're all in the
document here that have pretty more
comprehensive fall deal and concealment
laws
we modeled this bill against the
Massachusetts statute which can be found
on Page Six
in in the middle of the in the middle of
the page in the handout
now our draft are changed fraudulent
fraudulent con uh
uh concealment to
purposely conceal so and I'm not being a
lawyer I wasn't going to argue with them
uh why why we use purposely conceals
versus fortunately conceals
the member members of this committee
would know better than I why he did this
even though in RSA 508 colon 4-b
uh damages from construction the term
fraudulent concealment was utilized and
again that's in the bottom of page eight
now for the fiscal note
you know the only concern would be are
there going to be more cases because of
this
and they they uh the Judiciary said
there could be maybe it may
but at the last sentence they say wow
the total fiscal impact is
indeterminable the judicial Brands
anticipate such fiscal impact would be
relatively minor
basically
which which to me means it's it's not
going to be that that big of a deal
so Mr chair
I know this committee will give full
consideration to this the substance of
this bill
I'm at ready to provide more information
to in any work sessions on this bill and
assistant and with any amendments you'd
like to make that that may be required
I will take questions but again the
gentleman behind me will probably be
better able to answer them but I will
again I came in this totally neutral
on this we all get constituent bills I
knew nothing about any of this topic but
you know you get forced to research
stuff and I saw all of these states that
have forgile consumement laws uh so I'm
really trying to understand why we don't
um and I think this is a good bill we
modeled it you know Vermont has a pretty
comprehensive one our neighbors and and
Massachusetts as well uh so hopefully
you give this one this bill
consideration thank you
are there any questions for
representative abrami
seeing none thank you for your attention
Mr I'm going back to ways I mean so
thank you take care good luck
Brent Arbogast
thank you for having me here today I
appreciate it uh the opportunity to do
some good that I think is good
um
would you like me to just start why I so
um I I was a victim of a fraud
uh by attorneys
um
and I someone I trusted and I had no
idea
that I was a victim they basically they
used a federal court system
to set me up
um they weren't really my Advocates they
were setting me up because I had worked
for a pharmaceutical industry company
that
was basically
uh recruiting employees with saying that
a job was exempt when it really wasn't
exempt
and when I complained about it
they were very mean to me
they have to bake do a lot of false
accusations so they can get you out of
there
for a reason that will you know
pre-textual they'll stand up in court
and then after that
um or before I was terminated I filed a
complaint with the
Department of Labor wage and hour
division
and I'm going to take this down and um
the mass Attorney General's office
and when it started looking like
basically they found over 150
misclassified employees that were owed
hundreds of thousands of dollars these
are young professionals
uh that their college degree was being
used against them
there was a fight against a union that
basically they were they were caught in
the middle of because when you classify
someone as a professional it affects
whether or not they can engage in
concerted activity but they were also
getting thousands of hours a week for
overtime for free from these
um
employees
well the attorneys that basically told
me they were going to represent me they
were trying to hide this
um
and so they were trying to stop me from
being able to cooperate with uh the
Department of Labor and they would uh
given the Department of Labor the
impression that I was being represented
um they end up filing a lawsuit on my
behalf without me knowing without me
even telling them that they could
and then after a month went by they
brought me in and showed me the
complaint that was filed on my behalf by
people I never met okay and I was talked
into agreeing with it at that point
because they presented me with a
contract that said they were going to
represent me
and it was uh people uh that are very
highly esteemed in the state
and I went with it
um
well it turned out so I so for 12 years
or 13 years I went around thinking
I end up getting talked into just
settling uh and basically there's a
court record on Pacer which I didn't
know about that's basically
um says a lot of bad things about me
that they were allowed to say because
they were told don't worry about it you
know we're not gonna
say anything back we're going to make
sure there's no evidence available
uh you know we're going to break all the
federal rules of civil procedure the
local rules things that are supposed to
protect
uh you know a plaintiff like me with no
money this company spent four billion
dollars in legal costs in the year that
I uh that this happened
they also that same year was engaged in
defrauding the federal government
taxpayers out of almost one billion
dollars that they've recently settled uh
in 2018 but the uh the Acts were were
taking place while I was there at this
company
so uh when I found this out I have sir
tips surreptitiously found this out in
2018.
um
because I asked for my files
and that's when the attorney told me he
really wasn't representing me he was
just a local Council and that this other
guy was the lead attorney but the other
guy wasn't even licensed to practice law
in in Massachusetts never made an
appearance was not an attorney record
uh and so I started looking into it and
I basically figured out what happened so
I filed a grievance against this
attorney okay and the with the new New
Hampshire Supreme Court attorney
discipline committee and
um they have a similar we have what's
called a common law Discovery Rule and
that means
a lot of people a lot of times people
explain it with the doc with if a doctor
left a sponge or something as I think a
case in New Hampshire but if you don't
know that you were injured
uh and you know some time goes by
then the statute of limitations is told
however there is a caveat it says if you
it says that you need to be reasonably
diligent
so if you don't know uh what happened to
you
um then it becomes a subjective somebody
makes a decision well was he reasonably
diligent to find out that something
happened to him
so
um
when I filed agreements which was
um they wrote back and said you know
it's the same same statute of
limitations same Discovery rule same
warning everything they told me that I
should have known about this already
because there were documents on Pacer
this whole time that I uh could have
accessed and Pacer is basically a
professional legal research
um
subscription based it's fee based so
um I didn't know it existed
and not not only that but the contract I
had with them I was obligated to pay
them overhead for this for this fee
service
and they're supposed to show me these
these papers when they file papers
they're supposed to show them to me this
was you know in my opinion I mean
um they get a free copy as my attorney
but they hid all this from me
so the point is that
it seems like
uh whether or not someone was reasonably
diligent is kind of subjective
and
um it didn't work in my case because
there's no way I would I could have
known or should have known I didn't know
and I was I would diligently pursued
this up until a certain point you get
mentally exhausted after about the 15th
person that you have to
try to convince uh that what they're
doing is very wrong
so
what this law will do and it's like in
Massachusetts it's in Connecticut and
Vermont
if you can show that the person took
steps to actively fraudulently conceal
the action and you can show that in
court and you can meet that
um
standard of of evidence
then you don't have to show that you
were reasonably diligent you don't have
to prove that subjective
um
you know measure you only have to
you know they have to the only issue is
whether you knew or not
so uh in my case you know if if in other
words basically it comes down to public
interest
do we want people who can be shown to
have committed fraudulent acts to
conceal uh something to have peace of
mind through the statute of limitations
um or do we want a person who was a
victim of fraud and fraudulent
concealment to have Justice
um under the current
common law Discovery rule which actually
the court passed the court
um made up like in the 70s and then the
and then the legislature
passed the law that would that was
basically what the court said
and if you look
like besides these so it's does that do
you understand the difference between
if someone's defrauded and a person
fraudulently could seals something
and people are very smart
um and it's an important thing they
didn't want a class action there was a
lot of powerful people that did not want
me to know this they had a lot of
cooperation
um
now it's going to go to somebody to
subjectively say was he reasonably
diligent
and and whether or not I get Justice
depends on their subjective
um
thought about was he diligent could he
like Pace her I don't know what Pacer is
I don't think most people know what
Pacer is and even and I got a pace her
account actually after I learned what it
was
and within the first month I racked up a
bill of 360 dollars and I didn't even
know it okay and I know there's some
attorneys here that probably know what
I'm talking about
but it's a fee service but the point is
that I should
it was not a very good excuse to deny me
Justice
and that I think Society be better off
to prevent this from happening again to
hold the people who engage in those
types of fraudulent activities
accountable
and that if you can prove that they if
you could show you know it's a high it's
a higher standard if you can show that
they fraudulently concealed stuff with
the purpose of keeping this of keeping
knowledge view that you you were harmed
and that uh you have uh an action a
legitimate cause of action
then
um
I think that should be enough so that
you don't have to worry about
proving you were reasonably diligent you
just have to prove whether you knew or
not
or that you didn't know and that's where
the issue comes did you know or did you
not know
and that's the difference
so
okay any questions are there any uh
questions
representative De Lorenzo
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
Burgess
um thank you for your testimony I'm just
a little bit confused
um and it's almost like what comes first
you check another egg so
are you saying that the action that the
company took was found to be fraudulent
by a court
um
no because you can't even get to that
point because of the statute of
limitations yeah we you just need to
speak both parties need to speak into
the microphone
so the company yes they did engage in
fraud but that doesn't even get I don't
you know the person doesn't even get to
show that okay and doesn't even have a
chance to bring it because of the
statute of limitations okay
Mr chair do you want me to repeat my
question that would be a good idea okay
my question was this sounds like what
comes first a Chicken or the Egg and I
asked Mr agonas
um what
I asked him if any Court had found that
there was a fraudulent activity
um caused by the company
and that's where we left off the wage
now it did and they adjudicated it
so that I mean I don't know about
fraudulent but
but
um we can't even get there if someone
decides that I was not reasonably
diligent
even though I'm a victim of fraud I can
show that they uh did the most the worst
things uh to uh deception and here I did
I walked around for 13 years of my life
thinking I was just a belligerent jerk
at work for no reason because that's
what I was told and that they had a
right to fire me
and that's cruel
because
I
uh and it doesn't this doesn't
this doesn't have to do with
um lazy people or anything like that it
it's not a good business model the
management had no incentive to
streamline things at work it was a bad
it was they could just sit and say too
bad you have to work 10 hours more for
free
and they had and they would actually
strategically place uh professionals
with non-exempt or um yeah non-exempt
employees
that are doing the same thing so when I
got there I had to my basically the
senior person in the lab that trained me
and gave me instructions
uh was my say my my age
um she was not forty thousand dollars in
debt from going to study chemistry in
college for four years she drove a
Corvette and she uh
uh got to leave work after eight hours
every day and the people that they just
just decided arbitrarily were exempt
were were tens of thousand dollars in
debt from getting a college degree
studying science and
it it just wasn't uh you know like I
said they found over 150 misclassified
employees
and um basically this was
uh attorneys got together to decide that
they need to keep this covered up
and and
um I'm gonna be filing a suit in
Massachusetts I would have liked to file
it in New Hampshire but
um we don't have the fraudulent
concealment law so I'm not and like I
said I I had a this committee was
chaired by a judge a superior court
judge probably very respectable judge
and the reason given like I said was
that I was supposed to know these papers
were on Pacer and I don't I didn't even
know Pacer existed you know
so
are there other questions
representative wolper
thank you Mr chairman and
thank you Mr Arbor gas for taking my
question what I haven't heard from you
is how this did you any damage yeah I
mean
let's put it this way go ahead what I've
heard from you is that you were involved
in a situation
you went to the authorities in
Massachusetts and they found the company
was was doing stuff that was wrong
and now you say and there were some
other things that happened but I haven't
heard anything about how that actually
damaged you in any way okay well when I
got hired at Ys which is now Pfizer I
had to sign a release and authorize them
to look at my civil court uh Records my
civil core history
and
um I guarantee you if what is on if what
was on Pacer right now
that I was set up to be basically
defamed using the federal court system
they would not hired me and I'm a
chemist I'm not a construct I'm not a
carpenter where I can go over to you
know or a landscaper or you know
chemists need uh they tend to work for
big institutions that can afford large
pieces of equipment
analytical equipment that they're big
Industries like the Biotech Industry uh
the job I worked before that was the
automotive industry I ran an analytical
lab uh that they had hundreds of
manufacturing plants around the world so
it's a close-knit community
um compared to a lot of other Industries
and my career stopped after that and I
there were a lot of funny things that
would happen and this company kept
tracking me over a year after I was
there
and they would keep track of my job
searching activities on Monster jobs and
print out whenever I did a new resume or
whenever I did it I have no idea why
like I said uh they were very powerful
people biotechnology was really pushed
to Massachusetts the industry they bent
over backwards to accommodate that
industry and make it flourish and one of
the things they did was uh bury this
type of stuff and get together and bury
this type of stuff
so yeah okay and then
um I mean I could go I could go on and
on as far as the damages but it's not
right to just use the federal court
system to to have them publish things
that are completely false
um
and
you know it's a fault I mean our federal
court database should not be purveyors
of false news okay and that's exactly
what it is
it's all false stuff that they set me up
for I didn't have any Advocate I had
adversaries that would set me up in
retaliation and to to defame me and
discredit me and to bury what they did
wrong
um
and that's damaging to me and and the
society at Large
thank you are there other questions Mr
arborghast
representative Delorenzo
you need to turn the mic on no sorry one
question
um are there Federal contracts with that
company that you work for yeah Pfizer is
that why you're
able to file in two jurisdictions no
it's because all the stuff happened in
Massachusetts but because you know it
was it was a close uh call for me but
they they do business in New Hampshire
they recruited me when I was in New
Hampshire my attorneys are from New
Hampshire a lot of the employees
involved and it basically was a
racketeering Enterprise is what it was
they they hijacked the human resources
department and but they were from New
Hampshire so I think New Hampshire could
have had uh jurisdiction over the over
the issues
um and I would rather file in New
Hampshire but like I said I'm gonna have
to prove subjectively that I was
reasonably diligent
um I I won't have to do that
Massachusetts Massachusetts once I show
that these people fraudulently concealed
these things from me
then the only issue is whether I knew or
not
and they're not going to be able to
prove I knew because I didn't know
so
okay
any other questions
see none thank you for your testimony
today thank you for having me I
appreciate it
is there anyone else who would like to
testify on House Bill 1086
seeing no one
the hearing on
House Bill 1086 is closed
and we will take a very brief three and
a half minute recess until we call our
next hearing
questions
representative Smith have you filled out
a pink card
foreign
I'm
so
it being 1 30.
we'll call the house Judiciary Committee
back to order
and
for the purpose of hearing House Bill
1325 relative to the release of
confidential confidential records and a
person appointed a guardian
and will call upon the primary sponsor
representative Schmidt
to provide his testimony and introduce
the bill to the committee
thank you very much Mr chairman uh
looking around I see a number of
familiar faces or part of familiar faces
anyway uh and some others that I don't
know so well but I'm pleased to be here
with you today and it's a rare
occurrence that I'm in front of
Judiciary uh but uh this is a bill that
I'm bringing I don't profess any
particular expertise in this area but
I'm doing so on behalf of
um a sort of constituent of mine she
doesn't she lives in Northern Stratford
County and I'm the delegation chair so I
feel like I'm one of her uh one of her
Representatives even though she lives up
in Milton I believe
but in any case she is herself a
guardian of an individual and she's a
very dedicated person with regard to
people who have mental health issues and
are in a circumstance especially whether
a number of them that I worked with her
on over the years have been
held at the secure psychiatric unit and
that's become one of my uh
projects to try to get the spew out of
the state prison and and in a better
circumstance but in the course of my
interaction with Mrs Duryea and perhaps
some some of you know her Wanda durye
she brought this matter to my attention
and I'm going to be pretty brief in in
my testimony on the bill because you see
how a very simple it is and very brief
and not having any particular expertise
I I don't think I can answer any
questions but fortunately attorney Kerry
Tasker is with me today and this is an
area of some expertise on her part and
familiarity so I will I will turn it
over to her to deal with the issue
itself
because I do recognize from my
discussions with Mrs Durie that that
this is an issue which I recognize even
as a Layman as one which a person who
has mental health issues can get
themselves into a a pretty bad situation
in some cases
we all read about I think Britney Spears
and I don't know how closely the cases
match themselves match each other but it
certainly is the case that that if you
have mental health issues
and uh and and you've been put into a
guardianship that you've kind of lost a
lot of control of your life so with that
I've already already Pat you have the
bill of course and I've already passed
out the written comments of Mrs Durie
and we we have a potential of additional
Amendment which the committee may want
to be informed about uh and and have
access to uh once attorney Tasker has
finished her remarks so with that I'll
thank you very much for your attention
uh and turn it over to attorney Tasker
thank you very much are there any
questions for representative Schmidt
representative Chase
hi thank you very much
a question I'm confused I don't really
understand what it is you're trying to
do I just had another a law put into
effect on supported decision making
where a person who has guardianship
would be able to change and get some of
their
life back and make their choices I I'm
really I'm sorry Peter I'm confused as
to what it is you're trying to do here
well as you see online six seven and
eight
it's a situation where in some cases the
guardian has control of the person's
confidential records and the person may
have no no longer have access to those
records and this would uh this would uh
permit them as it says to have access or
to Grant release of his or her
confidential records and papers
including medical records so in many
cases I think the guardian judge Mr
chair uh you undoubtedly have a lot of
expertise in this area and that's the
purpose of it the um the potential
additional Amendment which we have
copies of here maybe a helpful they have
been provided to me by Michael skibby
I'm sure many of you know of him or know
him uh and we can pass that out if if
after attorney Tasker has made her
remarks that uh you if you want to hear
that I'll be happy to pass them out as
well so thank you
any other questions
thank you for your testimony
representative Schmidt nice to see you
and you're more than welcome the next
person to testify is Carrie Tasker
uh I don't think anybody would object if
you sat there
uh good afternoon
there we go thank you
um again I'm Carrie Tasker I'm an
attorney here in Concord with a law firm
Laboe and Tasker I have been practicing
in the area
of probate law guardianships elder law
for approximately 17 years I routinely
appear before the Circuit Court in
dealing with guardianship matters
sometimes I'm representing the guardian
sometimes I'm representing a petitioner
who is seeking to have a guardianship
imposed and other times I'm representing
the ward the person who actually is
under the guardianship the person who
needs assistance
um
so in my experience really with working
with the wards themselves the ones who
need the guardianship it has really come
to light over the years that these
individuals don't have access to their
own personal records
generally speaking when a guardianship
is established there is a petition and I
have a copy um that I think can be
passed out but there is a petition where
the petitioner oftentimes a layperson
will check off all of the things that
they believe the board the proposed Ward
cannot handle for him or herself and on
there is a list of things that has to do
with granting access
to confidential
medical Financial
documentation and allowing the ward
himself to have access to that to that
documentation the paragraph you would
see when when you read it is a little
convoluted it simultaneously gives the
guardian the authority to access the
erect the records while at the same time
revoking that Authority by of the ward
so the ward can no longer access or her
records I don't think that that is
necessarily by Design
I think it's merely
just how things have evolved over the
years in the court system by by use of
these forms and what ends up happening
is that majority of the time a ward
needs somebody to make his or her own
medical decisions and sometimes
financial decisions and I think that
that's appropriate in many cases however
there needs to be a reason why the
person the ward is unable or should not
access their own records
I have a actually a case that just
terminated by a a case where the woman
was
certainly needed a guardianship when it
was established and over many many
months almost a year
she really came out of the
um the illness that was causing her her
dementia
um
and having some cognitive issues and she
wanted to have access to all of the
things that were that were happening to
her her medical records she didn't
understand what the doctors were saying
she was denied access to the medical
records routinely
she ended up having
um you know some of the nurses felt
that it was inappropriate and they would
sort of give her copies or leave her
copies maybe when they shouldn't have
but it was very difficult process for
her to get a copy of the medical records
and the only way we were eventually able
to get copies of the medical records was
um by getting an order from the court
the guardian in that particular case
I don't know if she didn't want to
comply or or didn't want to release the
records I think it was more of she
didn't have have time it was a
Professional Guardian who had more than
30 Wards under her care and really was
not
she was busy to be perfectly honest and
the records were very important to my
clients and maybe not as important to
the guardian herself
so why I'm here is I'm here to say that
when a guardian is a guardianship is
implemented that there needs to be a
specific finding that there is a reason
to take away a legal right of this
person that he or she cannot access his
or her own Financial medical whatever
personal records They are
rather than it be almost a
blanket decision that is made
um
because of what is written in the
guardianship petition and what is
written in the form order that is issued
by the court
um
I think that there are instances where
perhaps the the ward should not have
access to their to his or her own
Financial or or medical records but I
believe there needs to be an actual
finding of that by the court before that
is issued the purpose of the
guardianship
um
is supposed to be the least restrictive
option for a person to have assistance
in managing his or her own personal
affairs to the extent that he or she
cannot manage them themselves so if he
or she does have somebody making medical
decisions or making financial decisions
they should be able to contribute the
ward should be able to contribute to the
decisions that are being made and should
offer opinions about their own their own
lives and this unfortunately the way
that this the the law reads right now
their
oftentimes automatically prevented from
having access to their own records
and so that is that is the reason why
I'm here today so that I can ensure that
it is
carefully
decided when to remove an individual's
rights to his or her own personal
records confidential records
are there are there questions
representative Sylvia
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um I think you're right this
paragraph is terribly tortured uh
should it not be Rewritten in a more
simple form
and and that might be might be true as
as well
um you just get that in front of me
um
the actual paragraph that is even more
tortured in my opinion in my opinion is
the one that appears on the petition
that if someone files in the court
because
how the form reads is it really is you
check off
certain things that you think that the
ward is incapable of handling on their
own so when you check off the part about
accessing grants and releasing or having
right to their own medical records it's
such a very it's a very broad category
and depriving somebody of a lot of
Rights without being able to further
narrow it down so I think that the the
guardianship petitions in themselves
need some revisions
but also
the law itself needs to expressly state
that you can't take away somebody's
right to their own
personal records with you know absent a
good finding a good specific reason to
do so
any other questions for attorney Tasker
yes representative Chase thank you very
much Mr chair and thank you for taking
my question I was a guardian for my
daughter until she passed away three
years ago I'm very familiar with this I
also was the Prime sponsor of supported
decision making which is now a law
what I
want to just know is are most of the
things that are coming up here and the
issues you're having are they with State
appointed Guardians versus family
Guardian it's it's with all Guardians
it's not a particular subset of
Guardians it's when you actually get an
order from the court which obviously
you're aware of what those look like
I've included a redacted order it's the
last two pages of this little packet
that's being circulated and I
highlighted the language that comes in
the um in the order and it's and it's
fairly
boilerplate to some extent when it's a
when it's included in the order
and it
it's
whatever type of Guardian is being
um
put in place whether it's a private
Guardian a family guardian or a public
Guardian this applies to them all across
the board so my experience and then
looking over my own case files you know
I took a sampling of them to see and how
many instances what was this paragraph
about having access to and granting
release of of personal records
um
and it was pretty much in every single
order that I had
um
probably because every single order that
I have for a guardian when somebody
needs a guardianship they are really
needing somebody to have
um the authority to make medical or
financial decisions so of course the
guardian needs access to those records
that would make sense but it shouldn't
simultaneously deprive The Ward from
having the same access
I'm not saying that the ward should be
able to make decisions with regard to
those to those issues but should be able
to have access to see what is happening
in his or her own life whether it's
Financial whether it's medical decisions
whatever it might be and that the court
only
Implement a restriction on that when
there is actually good cause to do so
representative Chase thank you just a
quick follow-up do you know when and if
guardianships have been altered or
changed at all
do meaning the I was to do and what lack
of control she had over her self right I
didn't deny her because she's my
daughter but I understand that so I was
asking is it court now when is the last
time that the actual New Hampshire
guardianship law has been changed or
altered is this going to be the first
time no I mean it's I would say I mean
it was off altered in the last session
of course
um and it's there's always bills I think
every single year about guardianships
um so this wouldn't be uncommon for
there to be a change it's
personally struck me this year to see a
certain client of mine's individual
struggle with not being able to have
these records in the in the actual
effect it had on her
um
it was pretty detrimental to her her
emotional well-being
um
and so I think
um as as I think you were you were
saying that when you file for a
guardianship you think you're getting a
narrow sort of
um limitation on the wards
um rights and that the guardian is only
being afforded certain Authority in some
instances it comes down to what the
court makes a finding about and I
certainly have experienced that the
court has expanded
um findings
in in
greater than what is actually on the
petition so if you
um if you were to look at the petition
um
I highlighted this as well because it's
so many pages of of
it's on the
one
two
three four it's on the fourth page in on
the bottom it says page 304
um with that page right there is sort of
the checklist of of
um
of rights that the ward has that we're
seeking to limit and if you can see that
they're they're pretty broad categories
and if I file a petition I often will be
very choosy about what I want
um
um you know sort of taken away the
rights of the ward however I routinely
see other petitioners check off every
single box even other but nothing is
left you know nothing is written in
where it says other
um and so what happens is that
um you know if there's nobody contesting
the guardianship
um you know these these they they get
included in the order and sometimes the
judge might make it an expanded finding
and include certain things that the
petitioner wasn't seeking also so it's
hard to hard to say I can't really say
why it always is is greater than I think
what it should be
um but I do think that it comes down to
a lot of times it being the person of
filing for guardianship not
understanding that they should really be
careful about what rights they are
taking away from that proposed Ward
foreign
any other questions for attorney Tasker
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today thank you
is there anyone else who would like to
testify on House Bill 1325.
seeing no one will close the hearing on
House Bill 13.
at this point in time our next hearing
isn't scheduled to be until 2 15. I
obviously misjudged how much testimony
we'd have on this bill
and so uh we'll take a recess until 2
15.
you want to give that to the person who
makes the difference that's the clerk
just pass it around yes
thank you
okay
foreign
we'll call the house Judiciary Committee
back to order
our next item of business is a scheduled
hearing on House Bill 1448 relative to
the pre-termitted air statute
and we'll call upon the prime sponsor
representative Lynn
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee
um
I want you to know that at the asset
that this is not something that I that
that is like a passion for me that I
spend my life on USC
it's definitely something I'm sure that
you know we could if you if you spend
too much time on it we could all be
snoring before long but I think it
really is an important matter
um
if I can start off
um if I could just take a second let me
read to you the current pre-termitted
air statute which is RSA 55110 and what
it says and I'm quoting now is every
child born after the deceased of the
testator that's the person making the
will and every child or issue of a child
of the deceased not named or referred to
in his will and who is not a devisee or
Legacy shall be entitled to the same
portion of the estate
real and personal as would be if the
deceased were in testing so they that
what that basically says is if you don't
mention
um it covers two circumstances an
after-born child and a child not
mentioned in the will
and
unfortunately there are there are the
way our statute has been interpreted
over the years but you know for a number
of years by the Supreme Court it can
operate pretty harshly to really kind of
undermine
the the testator's intent and so this
bill is designed
to to correct that and it does it in in
a couple of ways the first is that as I
mentioned the the current statute
applies in two circumstances
at a child born after you've made the
will or adopted after you've made the
will number one and then secondly and
this is where I think there's really the
problem a child that's not named a child
that already you know that that was
alive at the time you made the will but
is not named in the will
and it's the second category that second
category that I think is caught causes
most of the problems
um and so this the proposed legislation
that you have before you
eliminates that provision it doesn't the
statute would not apply to a child that
was born at the time you drafted the
will who was not named in the will and
and candidly I think you know the
the existing statute is based on the
idea which I think if if you think about
it really does not make a lot of sense
and that is the uh if you
Theory with regard to after born
children is you made a will you had two
kids and then after you made the will
you had a third kid and you just forgot
to change the will that's something I
think we can all sort of understand
could happen you just you know you had a
million things to do and you just didn't
think about uh changing the will
but if you have let's say two children
and you make a will knowing you have two
children
and you don't mention one of the
children in the will
you know the idea that you just forgot
about them uh
that's that seems to me that's probably
a a stretch that you that you just
forgot about a child that you knew you
had
um so that so the the bill is designed
to eliminate that um
that Circumstance
the the second thing and this is
probably even the as important is that
under the current statute if the if the
pre-terminated air statue comes into
play
there's only one result and that is that
the the child that was not named gets an
intestate share of the estate and that
can mean for for example
let's suppose that
um a person dies and has
uh for uh children and provides in the
will for three of them uh equally but
makes no provision for the for the
fourth child under the under the statute
the fourth child would get the the
intestate share of the will which is
which is much more than just a fourth in
other words it would it can it can
disproportionately benefit the uh the
pre-termitted heir another example
suppose that a person has a child
um and is married has a child and leaves
everything and and the the person who's
married has a child the the wife is the
mother of the child it's a you know sort
of an intact family
and the person leaves everything to
his wife
but doesn't mention anything about the
child in the will
under the current law what that would
mean is that the child would be able to
take the the intestate share under the
will
cutting off what the wife would have
otherwise gotten under the will even
though in that circumstance you know I
think most most people would say if
you're married and you and your spouse
have a child and and you leave
everything to your wife your probably
your intent is that the you know she as
the one who lie who do dies later she's
going to be the one that takes care of
the child but this would the the current
law would would cut that cut off that
intent the statute as as as proposed is
designed to eliminate those harsh
consequences by making the law
consistent with what what you know it's
reasonable to in infer the testator
desire to accomplish and so I think
that's why
um this is an important change
one of the one of the cases that um I
was discussing with your your chair just
be before we went on the record was
there was a case decided by the New
Hampshire Supreme Court about a year ago
and again I don't mean I don't in any
way criticize the court I think they
were following their precedent of the
way the statute has been interpreted for
years
but it was a situation where a a woman
had
um left a had she made a will in
Massachusetts after she made the will
she moved to New Hampshire she left
um
her estate to her daughter-in-law
and there was specific language in the
will that said you know up to the extent
I'm not to the extent I haven't left
anything to anybody else I'm doing this
intentionally
but she didn't specifically say I'm not
leaving anything to my son
and the Court held that the son was
entitled to the to take as a
pre-tremitted Heir under the statute
um based upon our you know based upon
the case law I've talked about even
though it really seemed
pretty clear that though you know that
the woman's intent was to leave it to
her daughter-in-law as opposed to her
son and even though as I said the will
was drafted in Massachusetts and under
Massachusetts law if the woman had
remained in had been a resident of
Massachusetts at the time of her death
her her intent would have been
effectuated it would have been proper
under Massachusetts law and so I think
that's just kind of an example of of
sort of the harsh consequences that can
exist under
um
the current law and this is
um this proposal is designed to
alleviate that and it um
it is not
the the procedures as you'll see in the
in the uh in the text of the statute
um it's not completely the model Penal
Code I model uh probate code but it
comes close to it um so it's you know
it's something that I think has been
thought out by people who really are
experts in the in this area and I I'm
the first to admit that I am not and at
all an expert in this area
um the last thing I would say is I did
circulate this
to uh the probate bar actually
it was a while ago now back in October
um when I when this was first uh
proposed
um and I I'm unfortunately I only
recently heard from them saying that
they needed they needed a little more
time to uh
you know to sort of give input and ask
that I ask which I do that I I hope that
the committee will not exec this bill
um for I think they're meeting they're
planning to meet next Tuesday and and
you know I've I've suggested to them
that there's some need for to kind of
move this along and hopefully they will
but I I hope you will wait for that
because as I say you know there there
may be parts of this that things I
haven't thought of in here that people
who really are experts in this area
would think of and would say well you
ought to make this change or you ought
to make that change
um
that that kind of thing the only other
thing I would say and then I'm happy to
answer questions is I would direct your
attention specifically to page two as
section two on applicability
and you'll notice I I try to be very
careful in in that section to say to
make it clear that it says this actual
apply to all Wills executed
before or after the effective date of
this act
except that this act shall not apply to
those Wills executed by a testator who
died prior to the effective date of the
act and I think I put that in there
because I think
if if on the day this bill became
effective
there was a will in which a testator had
not named a child
but had died the day before this law
became effective I think that that the
child would have a probably a uh
a vested right to to rely on the current
law and say I I'm a pre-termitted Heir
under the current law and I'm entitled
to take and I think if you were to try
to change that there might be some
constitutional problems with doing that
but other than that I think it should
apply you know when to any circumstance
where there's an opportunity to change
for the testator to change the will
and with that I'm happy to take any
questions
questions for Judge Lynn representative
Lynn
representative Sylvia
thank you Mr chair so on your last Point
uh with applicability
uh
will this cause people to have to review
their wills and change them possibly as
soon as this is enacted and how much of
a burden might that be
I
I think
it probably would I think it it probably
would uh cause you know I mean we
certainly would be prudent for a person
to do that I think
um
it because the the general intent of
this
is to make
the law
more more closely reflect what most
people intended whereas the current law
I think does not do that
um
my impression would be that that you
know it would not that even if people
didn't do that this law would would
would more closely align with what their
intent probably was than the existing
law but but certainly you know if I were
a lawyer and uh in this area of practice
I would certainly tell my client you
know my probate clients look we ought to
you know you wanna we ought to talk
about your will just to make sure that
there's not something in there that's a
that's a problem so I I would definitely
suggest that would be appropriate
other question other questions
yes representative De Lorenzo
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative Lynn my question is um
I'm wondering how
modern times are reflected in this um
this bill and I'm thinking about
children born out of wedlock
um that haven't that the
deceased hasn't reported to other family
members that's unknown and then what
about
um
children
born
through
um
artificial insemination or
like a not a test tube baby but
I'm trying to think of the penny
Andrew yes yes you know I think with
regard to let me ask you that answers
the last part first I think with regard
to in vitro fertilization or adopted
children I think this is intended to
apply
to any you know to any child whether a
adopted born through in vitro
fertilization or any you know any
circumstance like that
that the question on your first point is
if you know with a let's say a a
child born out of wedlock that
either the father or the mother uh
doesn't acknowledge or something like
that
um the I think the
um
as long as the child was known to the
parent I think the the uh this would the
statute would apply and and it it also
has the I I didn't mention this and
that's I'm glad you raised it because
it's a good point there is a provision
in here that says
that if a child
it applies to a child born after a will
is made
or it PL it also applies in the
circumstance where a person knows that
they had a child but believes the child
is dead
so that in other words if you you know
if you if you have a child if you if you
have a child
at the time you make the will but you
believe
um that the I'm sorry if you if you have
a child if you had a child but at the
time you make the will you believe the
child was dead
and then it turns out you find out later
that the child was not dead that the
child is you know living somewhere then
the then the the statute would apply to
that circumstance and there's Provisions
as you'll see in the language that allow
the court to consider the circumstances
whether you know whether uh you really
believe the child was dead or not and
those kind of things but it it is
intended to be comprehensive to apply to
those sort of
for lack of a better you know
non-traditional sort of childbirth birth
situations
representative Langley
thank you uh thank you representative
for taking my question and I apologize
if you may have covered this while I was
out but my question has to do with what
if people make an accommodation in there
will uh to deal with a child before
their death for example they have a
fairly substantial estate and they they
distribute a portion of that to one
child who's struggling during appear
earlier in their lifetime and that's the
reason they've left that person out of
the will
how would the court become aware of that
and and how would they deal with that
with the remaining children and right no
that's an excellent question and the
statute
does um does provide as I direct you to
uh Roman numeral two on the bottom of
the the first page of the actual text
and it it says it basically says that
the statute does not apply
if it appears from the will that the
omission
was intentional or the testator provided
for the omitted after born or after
adopted child
by transfer outside of outside the will
and the intent that the transfer being
lieu of a testamentary provision is
shown by the test before statements or
as reasonably
inferable from other evidence
so that in other words the one of the
real problems with the current law is
the testator's intent as the case law is
very clear the testatory's intent is
irrelevant doesn't matter what the
testator intended to do if you don't
name the you know if basically
the law is pretty close to being if you
want to disinherit if you want to
disinherit a child that is living when
you make the will
you pretty much have to say I'm
disinheriting Stevie you know he's he's
a spendthrifter he never treated me
right during my life or whatever I'm
disinheriting Steve and if you don't say
that
um then then the free trimmer to the air
statute would apply whereas this this uh
statute is designed to basically say
look the Court gives the court more
ability to really look into the
circumstance what did the testator
really intend
um okay in making a and making a
decision and I think that's a good thing
thank you
other questions
I think that
just so I understand the the way this is
constructed
it changes RSA 551-10
to now only apply to circumstances where
there is a child born or adopted after
the estate planning document the will
was completed that's correct and the or
or the or the child that you thought was
dead or or the child is dead
uh so
and the current statute 551-10 applies
to Cho not only children that were born
after the will was made or adopted or
I'm dead
it applies to all children children that
were born that aren't mentioned in the
will but were born prior to the will was
made so
the intent is by adopting this
children that were born during the
marriage will no longer be well could no
longer be deemed pre-intermitted heirs
that's correct in other words if you
don't I think under this if you don't if
you if if you if if at the time you make
a will you have children that you know
about you don't think they're dead you
know mistakenly you have children and
you know about the children and you
don't name them then then they're
they're disinherited that's you know
that's you've it's presumed that you
knew what you were doing when you made
the will and if you didn't if you didn't
name them as you know as uh
getting some bequest then then they
don't get any requests
okay and if I could take that one step
further so
if you did have an illegitimate child
and not know about it prior to your
death but that child came forward
afterwards
they would not have a right to take
I think that's right if you didn't know
about the child
interesting question if you didn't know
um
that's an interesting I'm not sure that
this specifically addresses that but
that's a very good you know maybe it
should maybe it should address that and
that that would be something that I will
I will be sure to talk to the sort of
probate experts on but that's a very
good that's a very good point
um
thank you representative Langley did you
have a question uh thank you thank you
representative Lynn once again
if if I had four children and one of
them expired prior to prior to my death
and then I died and didn't wasn't
specific about the will the court made
the decisions would a certain percentage
go to that child who had died children
if they had a family I.E that would be
my grandchildren or would it just be
divided equally among the three living
survivors a gen I think generally it
would go the the survivors the
grandchildren so to speak would
pardon I'm sorry oh I'm sorry I think
generally the grandchildren would take
by what's called representation okay
um so that uh you know I mean again if
they were that this assumes if you
didn't mention
the child you know
um then that that would be a different
situation but assuming that you
mentioned your four children and by you
know in the will and at the time but at
the time of of your death one of those
children had already died
um
the chill the children of those children
that is the grandchildren would take by
what's called representation okay
thank you
other questions representative Lynn
yes representative Simpson
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Lynn for taking my
question
um can you tell me how the current
statute deals with um the pre-termitted
air how that came about like why is it
written now as it is to ensure that all
the children have the rights right you
know if this statute has been on the
books for a really long time I believe
it goes back into the 1800s and maybe
earlier and I think
um
you know the with regard to the first
with regard to the first part about
after born children I think it really
reflects kind of you know an awareness
that people may you know write writing a
will isn't the first thing on people's
mind and they might write a will and
then have more children and they may
forget to change the will
with regard to the second part about it
not you know about what happens if you
don't name children that are born and
alive at the time you make the the will
um
I'm speculating to some extent here but
I I think that part of the issue was you
know there was more
more willingness maybe in in earlier
times where maybe people were making
they were more likely to make their own
will without the assistance of an
attorney that
um you know maybe people somehow people
really would be forgetting to mention
their children because they're not
experts at drafting wills and I didn't
think it was all that important and that
kind of thing
um but that but which I think is not you
know most of I think it's
a really rare situation today that a
person who makes a will does so without
assistance you know some kind of
assistance from an attorney or at least
doing some kind of you know online
research that kind of thing
um so I think that's I think uh I think
it's probably that historical
development
yes you certainly may
um
okay that's really helpful because I was
trying to figure out if if there was any
um
you know I think it used to be practice
to leave leave more to the male children
than to the female children so I
wondered if there was any attempt in the
law to
um
make that naturally more Equitable in
terms of how things were left to
children but it sounds like that's not
the case yeah I you know I mean I don't
disagree with you in terms of
historically what you know what the
practice often was to prefer uh male
children
I don't think that this specifically was
was uh you know was addressed to that
because it doesn't contain any different
the current law doesn't contain any
differentiation whether the children are
male or female
any other questions
comments
I would say that there is
a comparable part of the law that
provides for spousal share so that
spouses cannot be disenfranchised
and
and you can't leave all your money to
your
mistress right right right now and
because it was important as a matter of
policy I think at the time that you that
we not
make spouses Wards of the state and
perhaps is comparable in this case that
we didn't want children to become Wards
of the state either but right right
although I mean I I don't disagree with
you the only thing I would say is that
on with remember with regard to spout
the one important difference with
regards to spouses is
with regard to spouses you can't cut
them out in other words even you know
under under this under even under
current law if you say I'm disinheriting
my my son or my daughter you can do it
you have to specifically say that but
you can do it under with a spouse you
can't do it you just can't you you can
say I'm you know I'm I'm cutting him out
or I'm cutting her out but the law
doesn't allow you to do that the spouse
can elect against the will and get a get
the statutory share which is as it
should be as far I mean as far as I'm
concerned it's that this should be
representative Chase
thank you and thank you I'm just a
little confused now because I thought
you had said um representative Lynn that
that if the all the money was left to
the spouse that the child that wasn't
named could actually take that
did I not hear that correctly no no you
you you you did hear me correctly it's
the the
um
if the if if let's say a give it to give
an example a
um a person has a person is married and
let's just make to make it easy they
have one child who's the child of both
of them
um the the
let's say the husband has a will in
which he says I leave everything to my
wife
a hundred percent uh makes no mention of
the child doesn't say I'm disinheriting
my my son or daughter just makes no
mention under the current law the child
can't get an intestate share under the
will but I think that the distinction I
would make is this that in that
situation the husband has left
everything
to the wife I think what what chairman
Gordon was talking about is a different
statutory situation suppose in that
situation
the
the same situation husband wife and a
child the husband says I'm leaving I'm
leaving my entire estate to
my girlfriend Mary
the wife can say
no you're not you're we're you're you
know I get a statutory share under under
a different statute that's so that that
that's the difference
any other questions
yes representative notter thank you Mr
chairman it's a comment actually I think
I'm thinking this would make a good plot
for a John Grisham novel
I think you're right I agree completely
anyone else
thank you for your testimony thank you
is there anyone else who'd like to
testify on House Bill 14 48.
seeing no one
hearing is closed on House Bill 1448.
I'm obviously doing a bad job with
regard to timing today
but the next hearing is scheduled for
House Bill 1042 at 3 o'clock and we'll
be in recess until that time
because
call the house Judiciary Committee back
to order
our next item of business is a hearing
on House Bill 1042
that is requiring certain Health
advisory notices to be provided to
renters a vacation or recreational
rental units
and
first of all I'm just going to announce
I have a hearing upstairs and so I'm
going to be leaving and I'm going to
turn the gavel over to representative
green to run the hearing but uh before I
do that I'll just call upon this primary
sponsor representative rung to testify
thank you very much respected colleagues
I just want to say after the previous
Bill's testimony I'm very reassured that
my husband can't disinherit me so it's a
good day
for the record my name is Rosemarie
wrong and I'm a representative for
Hillsboro 21 which encompasses the town
of Merrimack
before I get into the specifics of this
bill I want to give you some background
about what brought it about in the state
of New Hampshire and actually around the
world there has been an increased
incidence of cyanobacteria blooms
cyanobacteria are among the oldest
living organisms on the earth and they
can produce the most lethal poison to
humans that's known to man
um
cyanobacteria blooms occur when water
becomes warmer when there's more
nutrient loads in water and they
overgrow and they form these blooms and
they release this very toxic poison
we have seen in New Hampshire an
increase in the number and severity of
blooms over the past several years
particularly the last two or three years
multiple causes for this in addition to
warm water erosion
runoff disruption of the sediment of the
lake
recently found that this is also a
problem in New Hampshire Rivers
yesterday I introduced a bill House Bill
1066 to form a study commission among
key stakeholders in the state to develop
a strategic management plan to address
cyanobacteria blooms and the reason they
have become such of a serious nature is
that when people enjoy our Lakes when
they boat they water ski they swim fish
and there's a bloom going on they may
may or may not be aware of the bloom
they can suffer very serious health
consequences
immediate consequences or
gastroenteritis skin rashes flu-like
symptoms
long term cyanobacteria blooms have been
linked to ALS Alzheimer's disease and
other neurological diseases
in fact uh Dr Elijah stomel from the
Geisel School of Medicine at Dartmouth
has been one of the Prime researchers in
this area
because there was an ALS cluster
discovered around the Scoma Lake and he
was able to link that to the prevalence
of chronic cyanobacteria blooms so it's
a serious issue I really hope 1066
passes so we can put all the great minds
together to really develop how New
Hampshire can address this at a state
level
and the reason one of the reasons this
is so important in addition to Public
Health is the fact that our Lakes
generate billions of dollars of value to
the state Lake Winnipesaukee alone has
been calculated to bring forth 17
billion dollars so we there's a serious
economic issue if our Lakes are are not
able to be enjoyed by residents and by
visitors to the state
um
my personal experience which brought
this forward is I'm a summer resident of
moultonborough and the lake where I have
a residence is Lake kanasaka and the
past two years we've suffered
cyanobacteria blooms and most of the
people that enjoy our Lake and it's not
just like kennesaga are people that are
uh accessing it through private means
either they're renting Waterfront or
water access
rental units they are boating
um very a small percentage of the people
enjoying our lakes and rivers do so
through Public Access they're they're
going by private means
and what we've experienced the last two
years is people will spend
thousands of dollars for a rental
property week or two weeks to get there
and discover they can't go in the water
or they go in the water and a resident
who's been aware of the the bloom says
don't go in it's dangerous
one such family nearly lost their dog
became so ill
and there's right now in New Hampshire
there's no way for those people to know
that there may be a risk in accessing
New Hampshire lakes and and other water
bodies so
we've also seen an issue where when
people do have the expectation of
enjoying water New Hampshire lakes or
Rivers when they rent waterfront
property and they have that expectation
of going in the water when they don't
they expect some kind of remuneration
from whoever rented them the property so
we've seen at least in moultonborough
Conflict exists because the rental
agency or the property owner
is expected to refund or give some
compensation to the renter
and yet the renter doesn't know that
there is a risk of using that water so
this bill
is intended to provide just an informed
statement to both the renter and the
property owner by saying that if you uh
you know if your rent and you typically
it's for any vacation or waterfront
property or water access property that
there does exist there could be a chance
of uh a cyanobacteria or even fecal
coliform
advisories on that water body and to
refer to a website that's on the New
Hampshire Des
website that lists these advisories so
it's really just so that the renter is
informed that this risk may occur and
that it protects the property manager or
the property owner in uh in in providing
this informed communicate risk
communication to them
so um I'd be happy to entertain any
questions you have
I was over here with a representative
page
thank you representative for taking my
question
and for your testimony I just have a is
the intent
to give the potential renter notice
prior to agreeing to engage in the
rental agreement or once they agree then
the notice issues if you follow my
questions I've given my deposit I've
signed it and then by the way here's
here's the notice it would be about that
when before the person enters into the
agreement or before they sign an
agreement their understanding and I
think I have the language here that
um
uh
um that fecal bacteria cyanobacteria
accounts may may exist so it's to give
them notice that this risk does occur
don't assume you can go into the water
body from the property that you're
renting
um you know I I really this is to
address an immediate problem that we're
faced with at the Lakes Region I'm
hoping that with more study this
commission might develop may add on to
this or develop a more comprehensive
communication strategy for alerting
people to these to the dangers
just to follow up for me sure my only
and the reason I asked that question is
the the
the notice issues at the time that the
rental agreement is agreed upon so I
wondered in my mind couldn't what did
that mean in terms of we've agreed to
agreed upon do you see what I'm what I'm
saying yeah
I think so
um I correlate it to on a rental
agreement it might say the balance of
your payment is due within 14 days of
occupation or a late payment would incur
five percent interest rate or penalty so
rental agreements have disclaimers on
them already to alert the renter of
conditions of that agreement so this
would be it wouldn't be a condition of
agreement but it would just be a notice
so in the event a renter
is at that property it's experiencing a
bloom they can't go into the water
if they go back to the property manager
and make demands for a refund or or
they're protesting the property manager
could be in a position say you were
warned that this could exist
all right uh representative Sylvia had a
question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
it seems to me that this may
somewhat advertise
New Hampshire as not being a safe place
to come and visit that's certainly not
your intention is it no no absolutely
not in fact many other states are going
through this Florida for one state is
experiencing very serious cyanobacterial
blooms so it's not to advertise that
it's really just to notify a renter that
there is a risk that these blooms may
occur it would also apply to Renters of
Seacoast properties I know that Hampton
Beach Northampton experienced several
fecal coliform
advisories over the summer
follow-up thank you um
so these issues with water quality
are passing things generally in the
summer I would think how long a period
of time are these
affecting water bodies it
generally most of the cyanobacteria
blooms I can't speak for fecal coliform
contamination but cyanobacteri blooms
generally occur in late summer fall they
can actually last through the winter
they can exist under ice
um so it's
it but it's usually when people really
want to go in the water when it's a hot
day
um and it's been dry they they want to
go in the water and that's usually those
that conditions that trigger a bloom to
occur
one last follow-up
and uh
as I read this I see it's it's not
limited to
um
places where they're near a body of
waters this is for every vacation rental
actually I I want it to go into rental
agreement particularly for those rental
agreements for a vacation or
recreational rental unit because that's
where the expectation lies that they
would be able they would be going into
water
thank you yeah okay
oh and another question over here
representative Chase yes seconds
and thank you
representative Ryan if you're taking my
question you're saying Bloom I think the
word so I'm looking it up oh there it is
but um so is this something that you can
actually see in the water does it Bloom
is it a foamy thing or or is it just
like a red tide when it's a high risk of
um it it's uh it can vary generally most
blooms I would say maybe
60 of them look like a green uh slime on
the surface it looks as if somebody's
poured green paint that's floating and
it usually will congregate around ashore
they can't travel through the lake but
there can one of the most dangerous
blooms just looks like sugar crystals
kind of floating in the
it's sort of just under the surface
almost might look like a little Cloud
um and then and usually all blooms but
not all will have like a little streaky
and it all depends on the number of
cells per
um I guess it's Mill cells per ml
that New Hampshire Des issues red
advisories that means they wreck they
can't forbid anybody from going in water
but they can put advisories like it's
dangerous to go in the water and they
usually do that when it's at 70
000 cells per ml
all right are there any other questions
okay representative Delorenzo
thank you missed it here
a question representative mom
so we're talking about
something
a condition that's an inherent danger
um caused by nature and we talked about
sort of like North Country properties on
lakes and we talked a little bit about
um Seaside properties so
on the same note what you need to put we
would have rent with a landlord or a
property manager need to send a renter
on a Seacoast property I noticed that
there are sharks in the water
no I I I don't really think it's wise to
put responsibility on the property
manager or property owner to notify
someone of an active bloom or advisory
and the reason for this is there needs
to be a lot of work done on the behalf
of on on the part of the state to really
develop a comprehensive strategy on this
because even they can't identify all the
blooms last year there were 30
advisories issued and I would estimate
that the actual number of looms probably
were 10 times that because those
advisories were only issued when someone
called in to Des when Des took a sample
and tested a sample and blooms can be
very transitory there could be blooms
that last for a few days some for a few
months
I'm aware of one bloom that lasted from
August into November same thing with
fecal coliform many times it's dependent
on weather you may not see that until
after let's say a rainstorm where let's
say there might be runoff or animal
waste that travels into a water body
that may cause the fecal coliform
advisory
and it's really difficult to say how
long that's going to happen and in a
lake too sometimes you can have a bloom
on the west end but depending on the
leeward side it could you know it could
appear there in the in a few hours so I
think as long as people are aware that
these things can they may not but they
can occur and it would prevent you from
from accessing that water which you've
had this expectation that you're going
to do if you've rented in if you're
renting that type of property
I don't know I hope I answered your
question yeah thank you very much thank
you all right are there any more
questions from the committee okay uh
representative Chase again thank
you they Coast I know when we can go in
the water and when we can't is this
something though that maybe Lakeside or
the state should be doing versus it
being the actual renter
um landlord
um I I think we need to get we need to
learn more about this we need to learn
the most effective ways of communication
and that is my hope if 1066 passes and
we get the HHS the veterinary Society
just a lot of these people together to
determine what's the most effective way
it could be a nixel alert but the danger
is increasing every year from these
blooms and people don't know anything
about them
um and so this is essentially just
something to address what we've seen in
The Lakes Region specifically in in
Meredith and in moultonborough That's
where I've seen experience where there
has just been very contentious
disagreement between people very angry
people
um because they have this expectation
that they can enjoy the lake and then
they're told that it's hazardous
okay anybody else
is there anyone else in the room who
would wish oh I'm sorry
representative welper
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh my question is to
do with the written agreement part of
this
um a lot of the rental that goes on in
our state I don't even know how it
happens
all I know is uh for example I was at I
have a timeshare
and people just
booked a timeshare through some agent
that we don't even know while we do know
who it is but we don't know in this
sentence being a person or anything
and
so are you saying everybody that comes
into our units we would have to hand
them a piece of paper that says are you
aware of this
well I think but they've already paid
yeah it would be at that time of
agreement when there is a when there is
a formal agreement that would be legally
enforceable that there would be notice
and I uh you know of that this this risk
could occur same it I I use the example
if a renter is informed that if they
don't pay the balance of their agreement
by date of occupancy there may be a
penalty I mean we we there are a lot of
disclaimers in these types of agreements
this would would necessarily be a
disclaimer it's just a notice but it
would protect the property manager and
property owner
from a complaint that someone wasn't
able to use the property as they had
intended when they entered that
agreement it would it would be a notice
follow up
that's exactly my problem
right because the people coming into our
units we don't have any agreement with
them we have agreement with our owners
because they're owners and we don't need
an agreement
but we don't have any agreement with the
people coming in we have an agreement
with a rental agency that's out in the
East or someplace
and I have no idea
when they might pay
because they don't pay us
so when they enter an agreement with
someone where they paid so if they've
gone on a website and paid
they they've had to enter an agreement
at that time to like they entered into
the agreement maybe years before
so I have an agreement that that if I
have points with RCI
I can trade those points in and go
places
okay and that's what I live in Virginia
or Indiana or wherever and I said Gee
it'd be nice to vacation in New
Hampshire
so I trade in my points I get a
reservation at a time share in New
Hampshire
there's no nothing between me and the
and the I don't know how we would handle
that
yeah
that way and it's a similar circumstance
I think with a lot of these gig rents
largely legal but going
on uh I have no idea no idea what kind
of agreement
a land if you go through
that's my problem is you go through
third parties right and there's hardly
any interaction between the rent the
owner
and the tenant
with the exception of allowing them
access
no I understand it and as I mentioned at
the beginning this is really like a stop
Gap this is to address an immediate need
there are going to be many people that
are going to be exposed to this risk
that have no knowledge of it
um for instance if somebody
um
loans their Cottage to a family friend
um they're good they're not gonna
they're not going to be aware of this
risk and whatever outcomes that they
experience if there happens to be a
bloom at that time that's going to
happen but this will protect some
property managers and it will inform
some Renters of the risk and that that
the entitlement to use water a water
body through a rental agreement isn't
um it doesn't exist you you don't you
can you you're not entitled when you
enter an agreement to use someone's
property that the water is going to be
safe it all depends on mother nature and
um so this is just informing them yeah
you're renting waterfront property but
there may be a chance that the water
isn't safe for you to go into
last one yeah one more follow-up
so uh along the lines of the inherent
risk of
fill in the blank nature
was was used before we've had many bills
before us
they were looking for protections
against these inherent risks
and
we haven't been very amenable to that no
this isn't giving anyone any protection
it's just alerting people to this issue
I mean I've talked about cyanobacteria
with many colleagues who've never heard
of it before and they certainly didn't
hear of its links to ALS and
neurological diseases
so if my colleagues aren't aware of it I
think it's safe to assume there's other
people that aren't aware of it that are
coming into our state or within our
state and and renting waterfront
property with the expectation of using
that Waterfront and this is just a way
of informing them that there could be
this risk and there and and also ways
where they can find out if there is a
documented advisory on that water body
it does direct them to the site but most
people going into renting waterfront
property don't just say oh I think I'll
go to nhdes and see what advisories are
most people don't even know that site
exists so this is a it's a communication
tool just to give people information
that they can make a a decision on
whether they want to expose themselves
to the risk if they want
oh yeah you got a question yes proceed
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question it's very simple
is the advisory is the only way people
find out through that website or Is
there any other mode that it's
communicated
um the way the advisories work is once
Des has been alerted
um that there is a suspected Bloom they
will gather a sample or have someone
deliver a sample to their labs in
Concord and when they confirm and they
confirm the level of of cells they will
put on their website an advisory that
there is a cyanobacteria bloom
there are Lake Associations that can
take it upon themselves to post a sign
um on nearby roads alerting people but
it's a sign that comes from the state it
it's you can't read it when you're
driving down it's a small print
they will if if the bloom is occurring
on a public beach and I'll use Silver
Lake in Hollis as an example they will
post the advisory on the beach
which makes it much more easy to read
and the the same process is is uh it
happens when there's a call A coliform E
coli contamination
follow-up do they only check the water
when it's reported or is there like a
time frame where where they'll go out of
their way to check for these blooms they
they really only test it when they're
told because there's only one person in
the state that runs the program and
she's actually just resigned she's taken
a position at UNH so
um David Niels who's the Fisheries
biologist for Des he testified in
support of 1066 and he recognizes this
is a huge hole people just don't know
about this they can't
it's uh they just they just can't go to
Every there's a but a thousand lakes in
New Hampshire they can't monitor every
one of them occasionally you might there
might be someone from fish and game that
notices a bloom and like I said there
could be a bloom one day and it's gone
the next
um but that one day when there's a bloom
um if a dog's in the water the dog will
get really sick and and I know of people
whose dogs have died going into blooms
so young children go in it's and people
just have no
um they just don't have any awareness
that this is a this is a risk and like I
said some blooms don't have that green
it doesn't look the water doesn't look
bad
it may look a little cloudy
but when people are vacation they just
want to go in the water
understood thank you yeah
all right
any more questions no more questions
from the committee
anyone else in the room who would like
to testify
I'm HB 1042
seeing none
you got something like that for the next
bill
okay
seeing no one else then I will close the
hearing on HB 1042. thank you all very
much and we are on break until 3 45.
all right get ready for the torture
chamber
all right now I'm stuck I want to do the
last goal of the day
Ned go sit over there
municipality command and Municipal
Association and talk about how often my
bill was oh yeah you guys selling
it I mean
foreign
Mr Clark I have to run so I'm gonna have
um all right
so much
okay
well representative Simpson
please let us know
yeah
oh yeah like someone leaves the room for
a minute I could come back I just go in
the bathroom you don't know
who are 73 right
yeah I like to call the room to order as
it's now 3 45 to
discuss House Bill 1073 and act
repealing the right to no exemption for
attorney-client work product
and speaking first to introduce this
bill will be the sponsor representative
welper
thank you Mr chairman
Mr chairman I'm coming for you today
seeking to repeal RSA 91 a colon 5 Roman
12.
this
exemption for records protected under
the attorney-client privilege of
attorney work Doctrine
this exemption
makes them non-public records
that is it means they they would never
ever
be subject to any question from the
public
they may not even be available to the
simply because
their attorney client attorney work
product
that is something to denominate an
attorney
right or
because they're subject to
attorney-client privilege
the attorney-client privileging is kind
of interesting
because
in the very beginning of the right to
know Act
well let me stop
start over
the right to know Act is about openness
and transparency in government it's
about the citizens right to know what
the government is doing
and how it's doing it
but in the beginning of that act it
describes what's a meeting
and one of the things that's totally
excluded
is attorney-client consultation
so if anybody any public body wants to
consult with their attorney they can do
so anytime they want and it's not
subject to the right to know Act without
this exemption
because it's already existing law
in addition to that if they want to get
advice or look at work attorney work
product documents they can do that in
non-public session under another
exemption or or exception within the
right to know Act
so my question is why in the world will
we ever add something that said nothing
that's ever done by an attorney becomes
a public document
we shouldn't do that
we didn't do that in this house
except that it was forced Upon Us during
the committee of conference at the end
of last year we never had a public
hearing on this idea
we never never talked about that in this
committee
because it wasn't an issue and it wasn't
an issue because as was presented to me
during that
Committee of conference it was existing
law
except it wasn't existing law the
Supreme Court had issued a ruling
earlier last year
in fact in April
that said there has to be a balance
a balance between the Public's right to
know
and the necessity in many cases
of attorney-client privilege
there has to be that balance because we
are on one side of the attorney-client
relationship We the People
have our elected representatives
in various positions across the state
and on localities and in the state
representing us
and those people
are going and getting advice from an
attorney
which is really advice to us
but we're not allowed to see it
we're not allowed to know what it was
we're not allowed to know who the
attorneys are
that's ridiculous
I think
and that's why this bill
I could ramble but I'm not going to we
have people behind us who have been
solely aggrieved by this already and
they're going to provide you a lot more
information than I will but I will take
a few questions if you so desire
and I see a question or I saw a raised
hand from representative Sylvia
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
this was just enacted this past July I
believe
and it was uh
brought about within one of these
Omnibus bills that came out of the
Senate originally as I recall do you uh
have the number of that bill that it was
uh so the bill was house bill 108.
and it had nothing to do with the
attorney-client privilege
the attorney-client privilege
part that is now this law that I'm
seeking to repeal
was brought into the committee of
conference
from the Senate
and that's why I say it was never
discussed in this committee it was never
debated in the house
because it wasn't
thank you
any more questions for the sponsor
seeing none
as representative
next I have
Laurie or tulano is that correct
you hit the microphone please good
afternoon my name is Lori ortolano I'm
from Nashua and
um
I'm a member I'm the vice president of
right to know Nashua and right to know I
mean right to know New Hampshire and
right to know New Hampshire is strongly
supporting HB 1073 the repeal of this
exemption
um
as representative ruleper just told you
this sort of snuck in in May of last
year into a senate hearing uh under HB
108 which had nothing to do with
attorney-client privilege or work
product and it came out of a Supreme
Court ruling in on April 21st regarding
the Hampstead school board versus SAU
55.
and that was a very unique case
um where a joint school board made up of
Hampstead and Timberlane had
commissioned a report to be done
because there was a dispute between the
boards that one board was treating
employees of the school district poorly
so they opened an investigation
when the report was completed only one
board was given access to the report and
the other board wasn't and the Hampstead
board believed not only should they have
access but it was a public document
because it was paid for by taxpayer
dollars the lower courts ruled in favor
of Hampstead and when it went to the
Supreme Court I believe they ruled in
favor as well and wanted a balancing
test applied to that type of report that
was a very unique situation and I've
gone through a lot of right to know
issues in Nashua I just came out of a
big lawsuit a three-day suit in court
with six claims and there's probably
been about 14
claims of right to no violations down
there over the last two years
um
and the dra acted on four of them and
found them in violation there have been
two that have gone through that were
awarded to the citizens and there's a
handful about another eight coming out
of the pipeline
so
um
I'd like to provide an example of where
I see abuses in this attorney-client
privilege and work product that's
happening in Nashua and I'm concerned
that the broad language of this
exemption what got added in Roman
numeral 12 will sweep away this per se
exemption that's listed now will sweep
away our opportunity to get information
that is public information that
municipalities are saying is
attorney-client
um in
June of 2021 my city conducted voluntary
right to know training I submitted a
request for the record records of the
documents provided to do the training
the city Legal Office denied the request
under 91a colon 5 Roman numeral four
this was denied in early July before the
law took effect
at that time any denials for
attorney-client privilege or work
Doctrine product fell under the
exemption of Roman numeral 4. there was
an exemption there it existed
um believing that this exemption was
misapplied I sought advice from another
citizen to file the request as well to
the legal office she too was again
denied
I informed the city that I would be
requesting and wanted the court to do an
in-camera review and would they ascent
and the city would not respond so I then
asked two elected officials that I had a
good relationship with a Department of
Public Works commissioner and one of the
aldermen if they would request the city
to provide those attorney-client
privileged documents to look at them and
the two elected officials did and I said
you can't disclose to me what's in them
but could you tell me if you see them as
confidential documents both of them said
no there's nothing confidential in here
I don't understand it within two days
the city released all the material so by
pushing it through and I was going to
file a lawsuit and go into court my
concern is this language that got put in
July 31st would now take away my ability
to have these records and I emailed in
the responsive documents I didn't print
them out I have a copy of this statement
I'll give to you but I emailed in the
responsive documents and the documents
the city used in training is simply the
right to know law printed out I mean
that's pretty what's confidential about
that they had an Excel spreadsheet that
they laid out in columns to show
employees how to track a right to know
they cited the exemptions and how to do
redactions they gave a sample letter on
how to write a right to no response and
then they gave two actually and then
they gave them the Excel information on
how to filter and sort the spreadsheet
that they put together to track right to
knows this was all denied
there is it's absurd to me
and I am very concerned that if I hadn't
got this in by July 3rd
I would not have gotten it now I did put
in a right to know request after this to
get in the
um right to know submitted to the city
so I want to see how many right to know
requests are coming into my city because
the city hired a dedicated right to know
attorney to handle right to no requests
I thought that was relatively absurd
that we would have an attorney for that
but I said hey how much work is coming
in how many right to knows you have a
list denied as attorney client work
product
I can't see the right to knows coming
into the city
what's what's what's so confidential on
here the only column is cc'd to the
attorney's office if you want to redact
that because you don't want to have a
check box and they're redacted but don't
not allow me to see all the requests
that are coming into the city and when
the city uses attorney-client privileged
information they use two and work
product exactly who's the client
I don't understand that
um so I I don't want this law
strengthened the way what was put in
there last year was a knee-jerk reaction
to a Supreme Court ruling that came out
on April 21st I believe it was a
reaction people's hair lit on fire and
they said oh my gosh all of a sudden our
work is going to be out on the table for
everyone to have no it isn't you had
Roman numeral four RSA 91a colon 5 Roman
numeral four confidential information
that's where all legal offices slam the
exemption if they wanted to use
attorney-client privileged information
and Doctrine as a as a withholding
I'm okay with that both to write a per
se exemption now that potentially
I don't know how I'm going to take that
into court
I I don't know how to challenge that
so
um right to know New Hampshire feels
very strongly that this language should
be repealed it really was not vetted
properly
thank you
okay uh we'll go over here this time uh
yes representative page please
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so it's been a while
since I've read the Hampstead case but
is the Practical effect of repealing the
exemption of the attorney work product
with this proposal be reverting back to
the Hampstead balancing test and you've
that that was there and are you
comfortable with that as
as where it is
I'm totally comfortable with that
because there was always attorney-client
exemptions through Roman numeral four
now it just so happened that a Joint
School Board argued over a document
being public and that was listed as
confidential attorney client privileged
and it went to challenge they challenged
it they had the opportunity to do that
the fact that the court allowed a
balancing test to take place on that
that's fairly unique and specific to
that situation and I don't see why
allowing that to be the case if you have
a specific if you have a unique
situation is a problem
I mean that's a very specific case my
situation of asking for the training
material used to educate city workers on
right to know to have that be exempt was
just
crazy I mean I thought my city would
want to showcase I found out kind of
under the radar that they had done
training so what's the secret that's a
that's a very positive thing to tell the
community you're educating your city
workers on the right to NOLA I'd be
showcasing that to everyone
they hit it and locked the records down
it's crazy
representative Horrigan
thank you very much Mr chairman thank
you much Miss ortolano um
if I remember what you said you said
they sort of adopted it with
this provision without a without a
hearing but I actually checked the
docket for the bill
that enacted it and it was part of like
some changes to other parts of 91a and
it looked like they actually did have a
hearing specifically on this amendment
sometime in mid-may but it's uh he's
right oh so is that is that correct I
guess you are correct I meant a house
hearing they did do a senate Hearing in
mid-may you're correct oh all right I
understand okay thanks yeah
anybody else
no okay representative Chase
thank you thank you for taking my
question comment who is it in Nashua say
or I'm sorry is it Nashville that you're
from yes I apologize that that makes
this decision is it um the city council
is it the mayor who is it that's saying
no we're sealing these records it it it
varies actually we have a lot of uh
confusion down there because there is no
Central record right to no request area
that your request comes in
um I'm trying to get a process going
where right to knows are
I believe should be accepted by the
clerk's office but you're left as a
citizen to try and figure out who should
get your request and where the
information is stored you know that's
not even clear and I think that's true
for some municipalities citizens go in
with a request they got to figure out
that they're going to the right office
that has the records so
um in this case it this request made its
way up to the legal office because I
didn't even know the legal office did
the training my original thought was
that the clerk's office did the training
but it ended up it was the legal office
that did the training and so it was
denied by the legal office
some denials come from you know an
administrative office
there's no set format to where the
denials come from or how the information
is routed in Nashua
all right anybody else any more
questions for the witness
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you
next I have Christina Wilson
you may be
good afternoon my name is Christina
Wilson I'm from the Attorney General's
office I'm an Assistant Attorney General
assigned to the office's transportation
and construction Bureau I'm here today
on behalf of the department to testify
in opposition to HB 1073.
this exemption that we're talking about
touches on two important legal Concepts
in our in our system so the first is the
attorney client privilege and simply put
when a person seeks legal advice from a
lawyer the communications between them
are deemed confidential under that
privilege this protection provides a
safe environment for people to obtain
legal advice from their attorneys
without it clients may be less likely to
seek advice ask questions or be honest
with their attorneys and forthcoming
about the facts it is considered one of
the most sacrosanct and closely guarded
privileges in the American legal system
it's deeply rooted in common law and the
Civil rules and the ethical rules
governing lawyers are written to ensure
that these communications remain
protected
the second concept is the attorney work
product Doctrine where the
attorney-client privilege community
attorney client privilege protects the
communications this Doctrine protects
materials created in anticipation of
litigation so this allows attorneys to
thoroughly prepare for cases without
concern that other people are going to
be able to access their mental
Impressions their legal theories their
strategies
both of these two protections apply both
in the civil and criminal context and
they are both critical to providing
legal effective legal representation to
clients
the Department of Justice represents
over a hundred State agencies licensing
boards and commissions in addition to
this under RSA 99d
the doj might represent individual state
officers trustees officials members of
the general court sued for acts
performed
in carrying out official duties on
behalf of the state
on top of this doj also enforces
criminal laws and prosecutes criminal
cases on behalf of the state
in providing these Legal Services doj's
Communications with its clients are no
different in nature from Communications
that are provided between an attorney
and a client and a private sector many
of the agency's boards and officials
that we represent are in regular contact
with us seeking legal advice and just as
with a private client the privilege is
afforded to those Communications
encourages our clients to come to us
with ideas and questions
and be fully open with us about the
facts so that we can provide meaningful
advice these ongoing Communications
enable our clients to operate and make
decisions with the benefit of legal
advice and in turn this allows them to
better serve the public of New Hampshire
to provide effective representation in
both criminal and civil cases it's also
important that government lawyers just
like private lawyers are able to
strategize and prepare in their cases
their mental Impressions their theories
their trial strategies are entitled to
the same exact protections that are
afforded to to private attorneys to deem
otherwise would put government attorneys
in the state and an extreme disadvantage
in cases and significantly hinder their
ability to litigate cases both in
criminal and civil matters
this is well established in common law
that the protections afforded by the
attorney-client privilege and the
attorney work product Doctrine are just
as critical to legal representation in
the public realm as they are in the
private Realm
the existing exemption in 91a doesn't
alter these protections it simply
codifies what's already been well
established which is that the
attorney-client privilege and work
product Doctrine apply with equal force
to government clients and lawyers
representing those attorneys those
clients and as 91a is presently written
it appropriately reflects these
protections and for these reasons the
Department of Justice is opposing the
bill happy to take any questions
do I see any questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you John
next I have a Margaret Burns
good afternoon my name is Margaret Burns
I'm the executive director of the New
Hampshire Municipal Association and we
are here this afternoon in opposition to
House Bill 1073 which would repeal the
exemption under the right to no law for
records protected by attorney-client
privilege and the attorney work product
Doctrine the legislature passed this
important Amendment to the right to know
law last year it was supported by the
New Hampshire Attorney General's office
the New Hampshire Bar Association
Municipal attorneys Municipal officials
and of course the New Hampshire
Municipal Association
repealing this important exemption would
be devastating both for local government
and for state government it will not
only jeopardize the ability of local and
state government to access and seek
legal advice confidential confidentially
and appropriately but it will also
create a conundrum for government
attorneys who like all attorneys have an
ethical obligation to protect a client's
confidential information there are not
two classes of clients clients who have
the right to confidentiality and clients
who do not that applies both to private
clients and to governmental clients if
all written legal advice to the
government is subject to disclosure
governmental attorneys will be extremely
cautious about putting legal advice in
writing they will be concerned about
their legal advice being subject to
public disclosure
chilling this kind of discourse between
a client and their attorney where the
attorney is fearful of putting legal
advice in writing is only going to stop
governmental entities and clients from
seeking legal advice and receiving
important legal advice that they need to
make risk assessments and decisions
about how to proceed
there was some testimony earlier today
that talked about the right to know laws
Provisions related to non-public
sessions that apply to receiving legal
advice as well as the ability to have a
non-meeting so not a public meeting
under the right to know law for the
purpose of legal advice
important to note that those exemptions
apply to a meetings scenario of a public
body and do not have anything to do with
written legal advice received from an
attorney to a governmental entity or
client so provisions and the right to no
law that would allow for a non-public
session or a non-meeting do not cover
scenarios where the attorney has
submitted legal advice in writing to a
public agency a department or a public
body
finally in opposing the amendment to the
right to know law last year and also in
supporting this repeal of the exemption
this year there has been some
conversation that it is the citizens of
the state or the citizens of a community
or a municipality who are actually the
client not in fact the municipality the
political subdivision or the state
Just Like A Private Client just like a
private Corporation or a private entity
a municipality is an entity that is able
to seek and obtain legal advice and
legal representation and again they are
protected by the same attorney-client
privilege and the attorney who
represents them is also subject to the
same duty of confidentiality that they
would for any other client
for these reasons we urge the committee
to recommend this bill as inexpedient to
legislate and I'm happy to take any
questions
do we have questions I see just
representative page please
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I know obviously this
question wouldn't arise in terms of
right to know where the private company
with their with their attorney are there
efficiencies captured that may benefit a
taxpayer through
a Frank advice that an attorney could
give to a client to work through work
product or attorney a client privileged
information in terms of
uh well being an efficient kind of means
to resolving a potential dispute if you
if you capture my question I I think I
understand the question and here's what
I'll say and I know that there are
attorneys sitting behind me who are
practicing litigating attorneys I am no
longer a practicing litigating attorney
in that sense but what I will say is
that the attorney-client privilege and
the duty of confidentiality that an
attorney has to his or her client it
doesn't block the client from releasing
legal advice if they chose to do so the
client holds the privilege and so in
some circumstances it's true that a
municipality a corporation a private
individual could choose to for whatever
reason could choose to actually release
or share legal advice but that is at
their option it is not something that
can or should be forced against them to
release legal advice that they have
received so I don't know if that touches
a little bit upon your question there
where you were asking about if there
were some circumstances where it could
be efficient or appropriate for legal
advice to be disclosed I guess if I
could follow up real quickly yeah I
guess in terms of efficiency and a
potential dispute or risk in mitigating
risk and perhaps there's some uh maybe
some other folks who are behind you can
testify to this but in terms of giving
Frank advice to a client that's
protected in a way that may resolve a
dispute
potentially or an issue in an efficient
way that may not that may allow May
avoid kind of the high risk high-cost
scenarios that could potentially be
behind a particular situation so in
other words if if I could give Frank
advice to my client about an issue and
talk frankly about the risks the costs
and so on it may in my view I guess I
don't want to testify but I'm asking you
could it potentially uh you know Make It
capture some efficiencies in terms of
how we might approach a situation that
might actually cut costs or mitigate
risk for for a municipality if I were an
attorney I am an attorney but if I were
an attorney giving legal advice to a
municipality knowing that the legal
advice could be forced to be disclosed
through the right to know law
it would give me pause about how Frank
or how much to include in my written
legal advice for fear that if it were
disclosed it would jeopardize the
municipality
um and put them at at risk and this
happens all the time where
municipalities have a situation that
they're Unsure how they should proceed
whether they should proceed and they
need to really lay out all the
information to their attorney and get
really Frank legal advice assessing the
risks and the best Avenue to proceed and
we would never want to chill that
discourse and that advice that
governments and municipalities receive
and that's that's the risk that we run
with passing this legislation
any other questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony
next I have the Tom Mullins correct
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee uh thank you for taking
the time to hear our testimony with
respect to this I am also here uh in
opposition to HB 1073 which would remove
the exemption uh I'm uh the City
attorney for the city of Keene uh quite
frankly I deal with right to know issues
uh way more than I would like to and way
more than I did 10 years ago
um the attorney-client privilege in this
context is absolutely critical to my
ability to represent uh not only the
city council for the city of Keene but
also the numerous entities that fall
under that not only our departments but
also the agencies and the other
administrative entities that we have
created the attorney-client privilege
allows me to have candid conversations
and also to prepare information that I
can distribute to my client with respect
to a matter that may come before it to
this question that was asked over here
in terms of efficiencies it would become
way less efficient in my office if I
knew that the information that I Was
preparing could be discoverable under a
right to know request I would probably
not create as many written documents as
I do now and I would have more
face-to-face meetings with everybody and
that would certainly increase the cost
to the community into the city to have
to do that I'm sorry to have to tell you
that but that would be the Practical
effect of something like this as far as
the issue about who the client is I hear
some confusion on the committee and with
some of the questions uh the client
clients with all due respect to our
wonderful citizens and residents from my
perspective they are not the client if
they were the client then everything
that I do under my rules of Ethics would
become an incredible problem it's not
like we have a monolithic group of
residents you know that would be sort of
nice about they sue us we sue them
sometimes we're in situations where we
have one group of residents who are
opposed to something that the zoning
Board of adjustment did and another
group of residents that is an absolute
support for it and if I were subject to
having to release the confidential
information with respect to a right to
no request that would do harm to one
side or the other but I can assure you
that there would be unhappy population
in the city as a result of that the
privilege is absolutely important to us
as a matter of practicality one of the
reasons why we came to the legislature
after that Supreme Court decision which
quite frankly was a shock to all of us
and not necessary to the decision that
the Supreme Court issued in that case
but when we came it was because we knew
that otherwise the confidentiality rule
as is being pointed out here does
require a balancing test under the
existing jurisprudence from our Supreme
Court so I would have to as a practical
matter again if I get a request the
right to no request for information out
of my office which I do
fairly regularly I need to take a look
at that and I need to look at the
documents and everything else that's
before me and I'm the one in the city of
Keene working with some others who have
the primary responsibility for doing
that test and seeing whether there is
whether there's a privacy interest
whether the Public's interest is is in
effect in balancing those out as a
practical matter it's going to be very
difficult for me to do that because I'm
then reviewing whether I think there
should be a privacy interest in the
materials that I've created of course I
am going to think that as an attorney
with 30 years of practice it's hard not
to think that at this point so as a
practical matter I would have to go
outside and get outside legal counsel
and have legal counsel take a look at
that for me and make that determination
of course then you're in sort of the
same problem because outside legal
counsel is coming on board and they are
representing the city of Keene through
me with respect to this matter so it
becomes an unending sort of circle at
that point
so I urge you uh please uh to uh to uh
itl uh this bill and to allow us in the
municipal sector as Municipal attorneys
the same rights and privileges that
apply to private sector attorneys thank
you for your time and I'm happy to take
any questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
next I have Jennifer Perez
thank you Mr chairman and committee good
afternoon
my name is Jennifer Perez I am the
deputy City attorney for the city of
Dover and I am here today in opposition
of house bill 1073.
for as long as these right to know laws
have been in place
can I ask you to move the microphone a
little closer to you please absolutely
I'm sorry about that just a little bit
yeah that's very helpful thank you
yeah
yeah it's time oh it is yeah
that's that
proceed please yes as I said my name is
Jennifer Perez I am the deputy City
attorney for the city of Dover and I'm
here in opposition of the bill
part of my job is working with right to
know so I do understand the importance
that the state of New Hampshire has
placed on openness and transparency in
government
but for as long as the right to know
laws have been in place there have also
been exemptions
for example Consulting with legal
counsel in person is not a meeting to
which rsa91a even applies
as for in governmental records there are
exemptions under RSA 9185 and for
decades these exemptions have been
understood to include without
qualification attorney-client privilege
an attorney work product material until
the Hampstead case that has been
discussed came about
when the New Hampshire Supreme Court
decided this case they imposed a
balancing requirement on the
communications of attorneys and their
Municipal clients and in doing so
watered down if not effectively
eliminated
those protections for governmental
entities and public officials
following this decision this legislature
prudently acted fast to pass House Bill
108 last year
which in part amended RSA 91a5
to explicitly exempt attorney-client
privilege and attorney worked product
materials from disclosure
House Bill 1073 seeks to reverse this
necessary protection
now I want to be clear about why these
Privileges and protections exist and
what they cover and do not cover
because hearing previous testimony it's
my fear that this legislation is being
prompted by misunderstanding about these
doctrines which are really quite narrow
so I'll start with the attorney-client
privilege
the purpose of the attorney-client
privilege is to facilitate the rendition
of legal advice
create a secure channel of communication
so a client can be candid without fear
of communication being used against the
speaker
New Hampshire rule of evidence 502 makes
clear that a client qualifying for the
privilege includes a public officer or
Corporation or other organization entity
either public or private
this privilege benefits the public by
allowing public bodies to get sound
legal advice
this includes legal advice pointing out
risks and keeping the public body in
compliance with the law
the importance of confidentiality is so
high that there is an ethical
responsibility of lawyers to maintain
confidentiality
will 1.6 of the New Hampshire rules of
professional conduct imposes an ethical
responsibility on all attorneys to keep
confident information relating to
representation of a client
in the comments of the rule the American
Bar Association explains
fundamental principle in the client law
relationship
is that is in the absence
of the client's informed consent
the lawyer must not reveal information
relating to the representation
this contributes to the trust that is
the Hallmark of the client War
relationship
the client is thereby encouraged to
communicate fully and frankly with the
lawyer the lawyer needs this information
to represent the client effectively
effectively
and to advise the client
s come to lawyers in order to determine
their rights and what is in the complex
of laws and regulations deemed to be
legal and correct
House Bill 1073 will deny this
fundamental principle to governmental
clients the candid communication that is
a Hallmark of the client lawyer
relationship will be denied to
governmental bodies
there should be no concern that the
current exception is overbroad
because the attorney client privilege is
not absolute
the privilege only arises when there's a
communication that is confidential and
made for purposes of seeking or
receiving legal advice
another limitation on the privilege is
the crime fraud exception
New Hampshire will of evidence 502
withdraws the privilege entirely when
the services of the lawyer are sought or
obtained to enable or Aid anyone to
commit or plan to commit in the future
with a client new or reasonably should
have known to be a crime or fraud
so the 91a exemption would not apply
if the communication seeks the Attorney
Services and assisting with crime or
fraud
another limitation is that the privilege
only applies for so-called control group
in cases of public corporations
control group test is the most
restrictive of methods used to determine
the scope of the attorney-client
privilege it limits the privilege to
Communications from persons in the
organization who have the authority to
mold organizational policy or to take
action in accordance with the lawyer's
advice
in short the attorney-client privilege
is in fact a narrow Doctrine with
existing limitations to prevent its
abuse or misuse
repealing the current 91a exemption will
only harm the ability of our public
bodies
all of them
from the three branches of government to
get legal advice
uh
have you submitted that testimonials to
the committee in writing
I can
would you yes
thank you
do we have any questions
I'm sorry unless you would like to move
on to questions no no more than happy to
answer
uh
if you're done speaking and if there is
no other questions
unless you wanted to move on no no no
please proceed I'm sorry so
yeah working
with product material like the
attorney-client privilege the work
product Doctrine is narrow
attorney work product immunity
ordinarily covers material prepared by a
lawyer in reasonable anticipation of
litigation opinion work product covers
the opinions or mental impressions of
the lawyer
this protection attaches at the point in
time when litigation is in progress or
reasonably anticipated by the lawyer at
the time the material was prepared
as explained by the United States
Supreme Court at its core the work
product Doctrine shelters the mental
process of the attorney providing a
privileged area within which she can
analyze and prepare her client's case
eliminating this protection would
significantly disadvantage government
entities in any litigation opening the
plans and Analysis of their attorney to
public disclosure
withdrawing work product protection in
RSA 91a means that every current and
future litigant opposing any
governmental body can file a 91a request
to obtain through 91a what they cannot
get through discovering in court
ultimately if the current exception is
repealed legal advice will still be
needed by municipalities but emailing or
letter writing will pose a risk of
public disclosure and so will likely be
avoided in favor of phone calls and
meetings
there will be little or no greater
public window into these communications
this legislation will not result in the
communication between a government
attorney and the entity becoming
publicly available
those records simply will not exist
in the meantime public bodies will see a
flood of 91a requests seeking past
current and future attorney-client
communications
the attorney-client privilege and work
product protections are essential to an
effective and efficient attorney-client
relationship
it is essential that these protections
are maintained for governmental entities
and their lawyers
the public benefits from these
protections and the current 91a
exemption
because they ensure the government gets
the best possible legal advice
but more than happy to take any
questions
now do we have any questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
and my apologize for the previous
Interruption no worries you said you
wanted my notes for this how should I
just give them to you now
it would be a lot easier if you just
sent them to us electronically however
you choose to do that
absolutely
great thank you thank you
next we have Kate Horgan
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Kate Horgan I serve
as the executive director of the New
Hampshire Association of counties which
represents all of your 10 elected and
appointed officials the association is
in opposition to this bill as well for
many of the reasons that were already
stated by the municipalities ahead of us
so I will not repeat but we would uh
like to uh just register our opposition
for this bill and I noting the late hour
will
wrap up there
okay questions
oh yes representative Chase please I'll
try no no well you'll know this one
could you just repeat where you're from
oh the New Hampshire Association of
counties
which is Commissioners all elected all
appointed
and any more questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
I have just one more pink card and that
would be Sean Jasper
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee it's my pleasure to be before
Judiciary Committee where I cut my teeth
as a freshman legislator uh 37 years ago
um
the right to know law is something that
is is very important to me as a matter
of fact the father of the right to know
law was John M bedner from the town of
Hudson and I served on the board of
selectman in Hudson
with Mr bedner it was so important to
him
that actually the fact that he is the
father of the right to know law is
inscribed on his tombstone in Hudson
and I have always taken pride in the
fact that I come from the town that
elected the man who gave us the right to
know law
I have walked out of a number of
meetings over the years because I felt
the right to know law was being violated
unfortunately in the time times when I
did that on the board of Selectmen none
of the press seemed to be very
interested in that fact and I've never
had the financial resources of the time
to take the town to court I've also more
recently walked out of meetings
that I serve on as a result of having
been speaker and as commissioner
and I'm very thankful that the
legislature finally gave us the ability
to record our objection and stay in the
meeting because previously to that I had
to simply walk out and then have no idea
what was going on
so I to that one board that I serve on
now I've actually brought the Attorney
General in to give a lesson on the right
to no law but it is a difficult law to
navigate at times it's still not clear
to me after actually having worked with
it for all these years because there are
so many so many questions but I am in
opposition to this this bill
I am sympathetic
to to the concerns of those who want to
see more information public because I do
as well
but
um
I'm not sure that this is is the
solution
to to a problem really and and I I wish
that I had known about the court case
that seems to have brought upon the
amendment last year and I really didn't
understand the the narrative
I don't think that repealing this will
be the end of the issue because it's
it's a one of the most ancient
principles in common law to have
attorney-client privilege and so I think
simple repeal of it where it's already
existed in lar and it's
a quick review of the annotations uh in
the Irish rsas show that as far back as
2005 the Supreme Court is referred to
the exemption under confidentiality so I
don't think that changes and that's been
noticed before but I I'm here to tell
you as the commissioner of the
Department of Agriculture that the
attorney client
work product is very important to us as
we're developing responses to many many
things we do whether they're
Administrative Hearings or responses to
right to know requests or any number of
things or just questions as we're moving
along
now it was previously stated and it was
a thought that I already have that all
this is going to really do is cost the
taxpayers a lot more money if this were
to
take place and be upheld by by the
courts that there were no longer any
privilege as to work product because
that would mean that we would all be on
the phone we would all have meetings and
instead of sending a quickie email with
the document that we're asking the
question about that really couldn't take
place anymore because a lot of times we
just we don't know what the correct
response is and so we've got to make
sure that we're asking the right
questions so that we can give the right
answers to the people that we're
responding to and and you can't do that
and then have that work product be out
there and people saying well see the
commissioner said well no the
commissioner said this would be my
response
what do you think
and then know you're all wet and quite
frankly over the years one of the things
whether whatever position it's been I
have a tendency to want to say more than
is probably good for me or the community
or the department and so the attorneys
are good in in keeping me in check and
making sure that I don't
bring liability upon the state or the
town
in those capacities because I was a
selectman for 17 years and was the chair
numerous times over that that period of
time
so I understand the frustration
but one of the things that the court
said in in 2005
is if it does not serve a purpose of
what its government is up to the
disclosure will not be warranted under
the right to no law so in other words
just because you want to know
doesn't necessarily give you the right
to know
now we we know that the courts have also
said
that it doesn't matter why you want to
know you may have the right to know but
what they've what they've said in this
is that there are some things that need
to be kept
private if you will and in this case
between the attorney and the client and
I'm I'm here and I guess I'm the only
one so far who's been here as a client
saying that this would this would have a
chilling effect on our ability to do our
job and the other thing is my memory
isn't as good as it used to be
so if everything that I'm getting from
the AG's office is verbal
I'm not going to remember it all
correctly and I think it's important and
it should be important to all of you as
legislators that when I take an official
act on behalf of the State of New
Hampshire I get it right and if I can't
have that in writing and have that
discussion in writing then I will tell
you right now the chances are I'm going
to get some things wrong and is that
what you really want I hope not I hope
you you want all of us who are
representing you and uh in the
government in general to get things
right so I definitely want
as much information out there as
possible
but I want it to be information that is
is useful and is right and that just
because I have a a question that I'm
asking that question should not
necessarily be out there for the whole
world to see
um and so I'd be glad to answer any
questions and I appreciate your time
do we have questions
Sylvia
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um so
this seems to have come about because of
this uh Court ruling and Ms odellano
stated that we had previously a lot of
things were covered as confidential so
we operated reasonably well it's always
bumpy with 91a
so is it really
necessary to keep this in statute well
you know I've asked myself that question
and in all my years as a as a legislator
I've I've learned that when the
legislature takes an action it's
presumed to have taken an action with
purpose
so while I would feel that there
probably wasn't a good reason although I
had admitted I don't know the details of
the case it was put in there by the
legislature so taking that out is also
an action which is probably going to
send the message that we mean what we
say and that the work products are no
longer confidential now I do believe
that because this is common law of the
United States and that attorney-client
privilege is very very important and
very sacred that this would be litigated
and that you're going to make a lot of
attorneys a lot of money by taking it
out and you're going to cost in a lot of
cases a lot of taxpayers a lot of money
so if if you're going to do this I I
would ask that you very much consider
those things and particularly the issue
of
you know is this a better way to
communicate with attorneys and is this
going to be litigated
if you take it out because I think as
as an elected not an elected official as
a a commissioner
obviously I'm going to defer to the
Attorney General's office but my first
response is going to say okay the
legislature has told me that every time
I have a correspondence about uh
um an issue with the Attorney General's
office that's now subject to 91a
um
that would be my my inclination and I'm
not sure that that's right so I would
ask you to be very very careful about
this and be very clear about what it is
you intend to do what you intend to be
confidential and what you think should
be public because I'm certainly confused
and I'm the one who's got to live on one
of the ones who has to live under this
well I believe it's a follow-up thank
you and thank you for taking a follow-up
so you've been in the legislature for
quite a long time or you had been
um
I don't imagine you recall when this
original confidentiality was put into
the law whether or not there was any
controversy or uh
discussion over whether or not it was uh
well the section that you're you're
referring to that's to be repealed
um yeah I I only learned today that it
was just put in as I was trying to do a
little bit of research and and saw that
it's actually not in the printed rsas
yet that it's only online so it's very
recent
and so I didn't know why it why it was
put in if I may I I was kind of thinking
back toys and I didn't write down the uh
the number that was previously and um
Miss ortolano quoted the uh the section
it's from which previously had
confidential records protected and I
would imagine that there was must have
been some legislative intent that went
along with that that that could be I
mean I do not remember a time in my life
when that wasn't in there
um though their confidentiality has in
my 41 years as a public official has
always been part of of 91a
any other questions from the committee
yes representative Lorenzo
thank you Mr chairman
um and thank you Mr Jasper for taking my
question
um I'm just feeling a little bit uneasy
because this feels like there's a
disconnect between what the Supreme
Court decided on this issue and what the
statute says
um and how is that settled
Well normally that is settled by by the
legislature unfortunately I have not
read that that case
um and it seems like there was a
conflict between two
two clients of the same attorney uh and
the court had to make a decision
rarely is it a good idea in my opinion
to pass a law because of
one one case that may have limited
application and I I'm totally at a
disadvantage here my my only concern is
that by totally taking this out there is
going to be the feeling that all right
now confidentiality is gone entirely and
we're going to be litigating this for an
extreme
an extreme extent for a period of time
and in the interim there's going to be
an awful lot of of confusion
any more questions
representative Gordon
commissioner
having had your experience in the
legislature though and your experience
in town government
was it
up until the recent court decision was
it
generally understood
that attorney-client Communications were
protected
anything that was was confidential as a
work product obviously
a letter to the board of selectman
to me from from the
from the attorney
in its final form I was thought was
subject to the right to know once once
that determination has been made and
there's been a legal opinion given I
don't recall that um
those opinions were ever withheld and
nor do I think they should be once
they're in their final
final form
may be wrong on that but that's
just as a follow-up to that so the the
only change
is the recent court decision
that's made this legislation what the
legislation which was passed last year
necessary is that your understanding
that that's my understanding as I say I
was ignorant of that until I came into
this meeting I was puzzled as to why it
was put in except
that my thought was because there is
always question about that and we're
always going back and forth with our
attorneys what is
um privileged and what isn't my initial
thought was this was a clarification
and now I I find out it's a result of a
a decision but I'm I don't know what
that decision is
anybody else on the committee
seeing none thank you Mr commissioner
thank you
a few minutes ago I just got one more
pink card in from James Kennedy
honorable chair members of the Judiciary
Committee it's an honor to be uh before
you here today speaking on this bill
hell's Bill 1073 which would repeal a
bill that in a law that was passed last
year by the general court
this bill as you know would repeal the
attorney client if passed would appeal
the attorney client privilege and the
work product Doctrine I've listened to
the testimony here today and I'm here to
let you know that uh
again my name is Jim Kennedy I'm the
City attorney across the street for the
city of Concord I've been there for
I guess 13 years or so now prior to that
I was an Assistant Attorney General here
in the Attorney General's office for a
number of years and have provide and
have been a government lawyer for the
greater part of 20 years now
uh I'm not going to repeat everything
that was said here today but certainly
the attorney client privilege and the
work truck product Doctrine are
essential in providing competent legal
advice to governmental entities that
require it on a day-to-day basis and it
should be preserved at all times
you should also know and I'll let you
know this is that with respect to the
Hampstead decision I was one of the
attorneys that read that decision that
was not a party to the litigation at the
time that it was originally filed but
after reading the decision I was
concerned by its outcome and how it
could be interpreted because how I
interpreted it is that it was
eliminating and abolishing the
attorney-client privilege in the work
product Doctrine a sacred doctrine that
has been around
since Roman times we've always relied on
it
and no the attorney-client privilege and
the work product Doctrine there was no
per se exception identified exemption
and the right to know law there never
was thought there to be a need for one I
think commissioner Jasper is correct
absolutely it's always been there it's a
sacred Doctrine we've always relied on
the attorney-client privilege of the
work product Doctrine and not disclosing
records under the right to no law but
when that decision came down we became
concerned
and thought gosh is this sacred Doctrine
now this privilege at risk
and so we worked with our this
legislature Representatives
in responding to that decision because
that's a New Hampshire Supreme Court
decision that was effectively
eliminating this privilege and Doctrine
and so the general court signed this
this bill House Bill 108 last year into
law and it became the law of New
Hampshire that the attorney client
privilege and work product Doctrine are
protected and exempt from disclosure
under 91a
now since that's happened you should
know that I filed a motion to
reconsideration in the Hampstead case
myself along with a number of other
Municipal attorneys as well as the
Attorney General's office
and requested that the court reconsider
its decision in that case
and since then the court has withdrawn
its opinion
so that case is no longer the law of the
land
however what I'm concerned about here
now is that we've gone to the
legislature the legislature has passed
House Bill 108 to make the
attorney-client privilege and work
product Doctrine exempt under 91a now
and over at by this legislative body to
remove that could send a signal
that perhaps it's not protected perhaps
it's not exempt but still of course
being a government lawyer I would rely
on that common law ancient law of
privilege and Doctrine and would still
argue that what I'm writing on my paper
to the Concord city council the city
manager the assessing director whoever
I'm providing legal advice to on a daily
basis is protected
but this piece I think in 91a makes it
very clear that it's protected and it's
consistent with 91a if you look at 91a
as a whole
look at the definition of meeting
okay the representative who introduced
this bill recognized it as such if you
look at 9182
where we Define meeting what a meeting
is
we go out and we lay out what a meeting
is but a meeting is not consultation
with legal counsel
so anything in that meeting anything
created it's not a meeting first of all
but anything in that meeting is exempt
from this is not even subject to
disclosure any that meeting doesn't
exist under the right to no law so
anything discussed at that meeting is
protected and that is rooted in the
attorney-client privilege that's rooted
in the work product Doctrine so having
this exemption in 91 A5
makes sense it's consistent with the
purpose and intent of the right to know
law
now I am absolutely uh in total
agreement with the concept and the
purpose of the right to know law and
having sunshine and what government does
and since my time in government
at the state level the courts the AG's
office and now with these city of
Concord I have seen incredible changes
in how more transparent government has
been and has become over the past 20
years it's remarkable well you know in
large part it's because of what the
internet has and what is out there
anyway
you know everything is online now all
the meeting minutes everything the
meetings that we have are live to
everything is there
so I think we are far more transparent
today than we were five years ago 10
years ago and certainly when I started
my practice more than 20 years ago
so the point is is Hampstead was out
there Hampstead was certainly what
triggered the the great need for this
because government lawyers became very
concerned
you know general counsel for the Supreme
Court general counsel for the Senate
general counsel for this body the New
Hampshire House Representatives
certainly when I was in ag I recall I
represented certain members of this body
in litigation individual members that
were sued
as an Assistant Attorney General and
established the attorney-client
privilege with each of those members
that I represented
I represented the Secretary of State's
office in litigation I represented a
number of entities throughout government
and to eliminate the privilege not that
this repealing this act would do that
but repealing it creates a very uneven
playing field it puts those that are
suing government at an extreme Advantage
if God forbid it was determined somehow
that the attorney client privilege and
warp product Doctrine was abolished
for government lawyers
gosh I go out into private practice the
first thing I'm going to do when I sue a
governmental entities demand to see the
work product file of the attorney
representing that governmental entity
let's preserve this Doctrine and
remember some of the things that we
learned today about it is narrow it
certainly is a narrow Doctrine the
privilege is narrow the control group is
what we practice here in New Hampshire
and certainly
um
in any event let me just say that it is
a doctrine that is rooted In fairness
it's rooted in keeping the playing field
level and it's something that we in New
Hampshire should maintain in as a as a
government lawyer and representing
governmental entity it's something that
I rely on every day
and I'm certainly open for any questions
representative Sylvia
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
it's not a well-formed question
it looks like a concern
leaving this in place and having such
strong protections for
the attorney-client privilege with a a
government body
seems to be at least slightly in
conflict with transparency and in the
case of
perhaps the worst actors that is going
to be a very possible Refuge
to do bad things
are you concerned that that
the image is is not that of transparency
I think that the potential to do bad
things always exists under the right to
no law in general
so because the right to no law dictates
that a quorum is necessary to conduct a
meeting and that the like right to no
law doesn't require there doesn't
encourage communication among members of
a public body
those are out there and those are
protections that we have but could
you know potential uh uh misgivings
happen from time to time certainly uh
commissioner Jasper said that they do
but the attorney-client privilege is
something that has been around
for centuries
the doctrine has been around for
centuries
and to the extent that there are Bad
actors out there
I think that the good outweighs the bad
I think that
um
creating that unlevel playing field
having a client and not providing that
client the protection of the
attorney-client privilege of the work
product Doctrine
is a disservice to that client is
creating a disservice to government
and I think that
you know is it against transparency well
I guess that's the basis of the attorney
client privilege if you hire a lawyer
you're seeking counsel from that lawyer
in confidence and that lawyer under the
rules of professional conduct both in
New Hampshire and every state in the
nation requires that that communication
be held in confidence
unless you as the client wave that
privilege
and sometimes it's appropriate to waive
that privilege right I mean sometimes
there could be something where the
governmental body says let's waive that
privilege and if you listen to me on the
first Monday of every night you'll see
that from time to time I'm providing
legal counsel publicly
and the council is asking those
questions publicly knowing that they're
waiving the privilege
and so sometimes that does occur and
sometimes there could be opinions out
there that are waived
but oftentimes there could be Decisions
by the governmental body where the
decision the public decision is
reflected in the council that they were
provided
I apologize representative page please I
apologize for the late hour to my
colleagues but if I'm a feeling like I'm
an aggrieved citizen where my board may
be used aboard in the town or city
wherever is
um abusing the work
attorney-client work product Doctrine
maybe just labeling things or I've read
things where people will of course abuse
that privilege and it's not really work
product or maybe it is and it's just
kind of becoming abusive what's my
remedy
if I'm a citizen from Exeter where I am
if I feel like my town board is is
abusing or refuse excessively using the
right to know so I want to be careful
not to provide legal advice as to
provide counsel to you here
as to how to how to uh file a lawsuit or
as like if I could just add but many as
a citizen but any document generally
had you know has to be labeled as such
and identified under the applicable
exemption
and when lawsuits are filed under the
right to know law oftentimes there's a
Von index created
and it may identify well this document
is not subject to disclosure because
it's privacy or this document's not
subject disclosure because it's
attorney-client privilege and it may be
that the court would have to determine
what those documents are perhaps what's
called in-camera
behind the closed door of the court to
to assess what those documents are and
so there could be potentially a
challenge well you're saying those are
attorney-client privilege documents
let's look at those and there have been
courts that have actually done that have
looked at the the the exemption and the
scope of the attorney client privilege
for instance billing records were once
challenged and there's a certain
threshold of what billing records of the
attorney to the governmental entity have
to be disclosed and so
you could certainly uh make the inquiry
of the body you know what it what is it
that um is being uh withheld and why
um and uh the bot the bodies required to
identify the exemption as to what is
being withheld
um but certainly at the end of the day
if there's litigation a court would be
the ultimate determinant determination
as to what whether or not that specific
document is subject to disclosure
okay anyone else any other questions
yes representative dilorenzo
Mr chairman and thank you if you take
questions
um
attorney Kennedy could you just
go back over what happened with the
court case
involved with SAU 55 you said that
you've filed a motion for
reconsideration and the decision was
withdrawn that's correct okay I mean
I've never heard of that before how does
that work so it's no longer president
um
it was a it it it I guess it's not
unprecedented but
um uh the municipal bar as well as the
um Attorney General's office had
reviewed the decision and made a
decision that we would file what's
called an amicus brief or an amicus
memorandum of Law and file a motion for
reconsideration
um in the court thereafter reviewed it
there was never ultimately a decision on
it but the parties because they had uh
uh
resolved the matter I believe amically
outside a Judicial decision it was
ultimately withdrawn the decision was
withdrawn
oh follow up sure um would you be able
to provide the committee with a citation
on that
um sure we can find I can send something
over I guess to the chair or something
okay thank you
any other questions
thank you for your testimony
is there anyone else in the room who
wishes to testify on House Bill 1073.
and seeing them I will close the hearing
on House Bill 1073.
and that includes concludes the
committee's business for the day and we
will reconvene uh we'll be in recess and
reconvene the committee on the 19th at
nine o'clock for further hearings
right exactly
oh okay
I was like I'm sure
okay thank you
very thank you
that scares me
oh okay yes
yeah